this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
Dumbo everybody in hello everyone
whoever you are in the world and a very
warm welcome to our sunset Safari Drive
all the way from Masai Mara as always my
name is David and filming me today is
Archie Archie how are you doing are you
excited a cheese just smiling and not
telling me anything but I can tell from
this while he is very excited one one
comes to all of you and remember most
important you have questions your
comments
hashtag Safari live gives us lots of joy
please keep sending your questions any
comments you may have from what I'll be
showing you we have just started the
strong heart of buffalos now and Archie
is very just to go back to the Buffaloes
and remember we are coming to you from
Kenya in the Mara Game Reserve and
specifically in the Mara triangle and
how exciting to have let's buffalos
there and some white birds hitchhiking
on them and we'll call those the cattle
egrets a bit warm now and that's why you
see these big buffaloes just rusting
some of them could be chewing khat
ruminating as you say as usual flicking
the tails flies and what will happen as
it cools off there start rising up they
flick the tails they flick the ears all
those irritating flies they keep them
away funny how flies to choose or choose
to go to the very sensitive parts of the
animals the ears there's an ox pick on
top of that one there actually look
carefully there's a bird on top there
and yes well done Archie and these are
the ox pickers and if you look at that
patch where those two birds are it looks
a bit better the fire's gone and they're
big Alexei's
Kings fire that's a great comment yeah
Buffalo's and what I will do me and
Archie will count how many buffaloes are
here analysis a year Buffalo's out guess
it's a hundred as I said earlier plus
what I won't arch to do I want you to
count the females and I will count the
males are you with me and then we will
see buffaloes any day it's good to see
you can see that from ruminating there
they must be having very strong ear
muscles you can tell when they keep
flicking their muscles or their ears
like that the whole day strange you
don't see the flies that are irritating
this particular female here and I'm
saying the female because you can tell
by the size of her Hans
they are not as large especially at the
base the oxpecker comes in so what I do
not know is whether she's flicking
because of the flies or the oxpeckers or
both I'm still counting and it's pretty
big hard here so what we'll do we'll try
and go around on the other side and see
how many buffaloes you might be having
in turtle and if it cools up a little
bit later I'm sure they all gonna rise
and shine and starts moving around so
what are they doing now is just to you
know to cut which her ruminating as I
said before and I want to give you a
different angle and see how it looks
some are standing some are laying down
and a feel are grazing
actually is one that has a very pink
nose there can I see that one Archie
Thank You Artie that's pink that's nice
very pink I do not know what that could
mean to me I don't know whether it could
be some skin infection but yeah I mean
that's nurse is very very pink I'll be
finding out why this this is very pink
but in the meantime I want to take you
all the way to South Africa there's
another young man who would like to say
hello to all of you
good afternoon David thank you for
calling me a young man many thank you
hello everybody my name is Steve I'm
joined on camera by Craig we are down
here in the sabi sands juma South Africa
where the way there's 23 degrees and 72
degrees Fahrenheit there's a lovely
afternoon arts and the rain has cleared
up there's a beautiful beautiful life in
us a little bit windy and we're gonna
see if maybe we can find any tracks of
maybe 10 Ghana this morning the drone
went out we managed to find lions we
managed to find Rosana and we found a
hot spot but unfortunately both James
and Tristan were busy and then we
weren't able to follow up on the hot
spot and then from the area where I had
that hot spot we quite identify it but
you know we get into that point where we
kind of sure that's a cat and then there
was a leopard calling from that sort of
general area sound locked in Ghana a
short sort of bursts mail call and
Impala were going nuts but we didn't
find him so we're gonna see if maybe we
can find where the Jukka might be not
far I'm sure from where hosanna was
originally found as we know these two
have a little bit of a father-son
bromance which is really really
interesting please ladies and gentlemen
feel free sent to your questions and
comments hashtag Safari lab or jump on
the YouTube chat stream let us know how
you're doing this afternoon there's a
wonderful day out
Craig and I excited we'd own what it's
going to herald but after a little bit
of rain a little bit of Sun who knows
what can materialize as you know this is
all coming to you live from Juma and the
Maasai Mara we have no doubt David is
extremely excited to be out he's such a
lovely gentleman he's so proud to be
showing you his home I'm going to be
joined out by Tristan and shortly I
think he's got some plans to follow up
on a little chief from this morning was
really quite interesting watching James
and the little chief this morning from
the drone trying to do some hunting
really is special to have that
bird's-eye view
but it's still very dry out the rain
doesn't seem to have done too much but
those little burnt areas where the fire
has been I'm sure with that little bit
of rain we're gonna see it's a tiny
flush in the next day or two so we're
probably gonna have a little look at
that and see what else is potting our
chair in the African wilderness and in
the meantime let's go with the Trista
themself and see exactly what his plans
are well good afternoon everyone and
welcome to our sunset Safari as Steve
mentioned my name is Tristan on camera
I've got Fergus this afternoon and our
plan well we're going to amble about and
see what we can find a good check up on
way James Ross head of asana see what
he's been up to but otherwise we're
going to try and just kind of see what
the day brings us there's a bit of
sunshine oh hello impalas Phil have a
look at these guys why not they right in
front of us so just see what the
afternoon brings us the Sun has come out
now which is quite nice and that means
that hopefully we're gonna get a little
bit of action as the day heats up it's
still quite cool in comparison to a few
days ago but it is far far far better
than what poor James and Steve dealt
with yesterday afternoon in that rain
and blustery wind and freezing cold so
at least there's a bit of sunshine and
sunshine generally promotes good game
viewing we normally see a lot of animals
moving about in the afternoon if the Sun
is arts and that's normally because they
go down for drink so well hang about the
pans we'll get checked triage down I
know Steve's gonna be around as well
between the two of us we'll just kind of
scratch around
unfortunately the Inca Houma pride from
this morning have all vanished they all
went into arethusa
and continued south from the journey and
I think they got a bit rattled by those
over cos this morning and therefore
decided to move off a little bit but
you'll see these impalas are fairly wary
I'm pretty sure this is the same heard
of impalas and has probably spent much
of the day in this area and the one that
husana was terrorizing this morning and
they must have felt like they were
between a rock and a hard place this
morning because there was Kasana there
was lions roaring all over the place
it couldn't have been pleasant to be in
a husband to be an Impala overnight in
the early hours of this morning because
there was just threats coming from every
direction but they seemed as though they
came out of it unscathed and well
everybody looks quite fine about life at
this stage
King sigh I would say 4122 give or take
one or two no I'm joking I honestly have
absolutely no idea how many impalas are
living on Juma at any one time you know
because they move so much and we see
them crossing Gauri main we see them
crossing into tortured muffles look
arethusa it's really difficult to know I
mean it I think conditions will
fluctuate that number so we'll
temperature so we'll wind so I mean it
varies day to day it will be different
but I would say at any one time minimum
we would probably they would probably be
at least two to three hundred of these
guys spread across Juma quite easily in
fact probably even more it's difficult
to say between you've got one or two
really big herds that are a number over
50 60 individuals together and then lots
of smaller groupings so there's there's
a lot of them and then they are as you
know very common and we see them pretty
regularly and so that's always nice
though I quite like impalas I know that
they've got this bad reputation amongst
a lot of South African bush goers and
that they're boring and that people
stopping for them was boring but for me
and Impala is a beautiful animal and it
is often a great animal to stop with
because the amount of times I've stopped
with him impalas and set chatting like
this and either heard other impalas
alarm call all those very impalas will
bless you well and now what's a frog in
your throat all making an alarm call
which is maybe what they were trying to
kind of show me and is is numerous and
from there you then find a predator so I
find they're they're a good animal to
just stop and have a little look around
and just see what's going on before and
I'm just dismissing them as a common
tentative good well we are going to
carry on and while we do that and try
and see what else we can find David is
still sitting with another hood and I'm
will accept they're far more grumpy and
far bigger than these Impala buffaloes
year and you remember we someone that
had their red you know new scent was
very pinkish rather not red and my guess
was that could have been like you know a
skin condition of a kind
I'm afraid this one that's been yes well
done Archie look at
and we've been trying to I've been
trying to think there's a condition in
human beings could Vettel ego or some
kind of lack of melanin in that
particular part of the nose and I
wouldn't want to believe it God some you
know skin band from the time but I would
say it could be a skin condition or it
could mean a genetical you know
happening on it and most likely is I
could be a good idea could see the
offspring or this particular one or
maybe its mother and find out whether it
was something running in it genetically
but yes that's quite unusual I don't
remember seeing another one with another
pink nose like that and that he keeps
walking Kimberly that's a great comment
could be a son but and I thought it
could be possibly that it could be
possibly a sunburn it's very possible
but I don't think it's more of a skin
condition which is dinner to because
most buffaloes like now it's rather warm
and they're out in the Sun and if they
would have any issues or thing to be
more on the eyes but on the skin I
highly doubt we have strong Sun here but
the buffaloes are bullets no no it's too
strong either they get some good cover
all these stay under some trees on they
stay under the grass like you can see
here now the nurses tend to be bending
downwards and not looking up in the sky
so my guess is it could be more of a
condition of a genetic condition then
you know a skin issue but those are very
good thoughts you never know we had lots
of them lots of oxpeckers on some of the
Buffaloes yeah like that one's having
one writing on it and this is the
yellow-billed ox speaker we normally
have two types of rock speakers either
the yellow-billed or the red-billed
oxpecker i'm trying to get a picture to
see nicely how the ox peak has looked
like
Margareta that's a very good question
you see buffaloes are ruminants and they
got four chambered stomachs and what
they will do they keep feeding they keep
feeding be it cross and mainly buffalos
are grazers once they have taken enough
they'll tend to rest that's one big
advantage of animals that do room in it
and when they rest they regard it or
they have eaten and they riku it again
to be more fine particles we're going to
be looking back to these buffaloes again
with Archie and you see some that a
chewing card and some that are not and
margarita that's what will happen they
tend to get the best is how in my
village long time ago I can't remember
maybe during my mother's time our
grandmother who my grandmother
especially who is still alive you used
to tell me she even tells me today long
time the women in the village would get
bananas and just roast them in the fire
and once there draws them in the fire
they'll chew the bananas and then remove
what they have sent chilled from the
mouth and feed to their children so I'm
trying to compare that explanation for
my grandmother to what maybe the
buffalos or animals that ruminants do so
keep eating cut into smaller pieces
swallow it cut in smaller pieces swallow
and then once you rest like the one I
just showing you there you regard it
that means you bring it out margarita
and yoora to it to more fine particles
and that way you get more neutrons from
what you've cheered but it seems to have
an issue there on his genitalia
some swollen parts I'm sure that's very
know I'm seeing some very interesting a
ID stream the buffalos we had the pink
nose and then this one on the genitalia
have like some swellings but this also
happens to the cows once in the oil it
could be a kind of a tumor who knows and
you can see it's not very comfortable as
she keeps or keeps flicking the tail
there and the angle the tail is resting
it's not there we should be
because of that swelling there on the
left side well just like you know human
beings animals also get some kind of I
did some tumor or I don't know it's kind
of some kind of a cancer if I'm not a
specialist I would not be able to know
and if you look at the health condition
of that particular one doesn't look very
good a lot of files missing on the body
and I'm not sure it's the effect of that
is a tenth have a way yes and that tells
you she is definitely a girl and yes so
much issues on the genitalia parts above
the vagina there just near the owners
you can tell the swelling's in that area
time to scratch excellent sorry make any
missed you question about the orc
speaker
okk speakers yes yes and then we saw the
interesting thing and my oak speakers
are still here and we were seeing
earlier the yellow blocks because if you
come to me here Archie excellent
that's a yellow bill dog speakers on top
there and these are the ones that we sue
on top of those buffaloes here we got
two types of ox because we got the
yellow bill dog speaker and we also got
their red bilac speaker I remember when
I was in South Africa couple of weeks
ago I kept seeing more red Wheelock
speakers than the yellow blocks because
let's now go to the red blocks speakers
and see the difference between the two
and there is on top there well done
Archie that's the red build ox speakers
and the main difference would be only a
big as the name suggests the Airblade or
red build the red bill is all red all
the way on the beak but the yellow block
speakers have both yellow and red but
when you see the immature ones like the
one you see there they good not very
clear red or yellow this being an
immature of a red build ox speaker does
not have any amount of red in it until
it matures from immature becomes a
juvenile one and then it becomes an
adult alrighty we'll have to move on now
I've done a bit of three on those
buffaloes but I think Trish and got an
interesting cut in South Africa
well we do have probably the most
interesting cat hello husana welcome to
this afternoon's show he is busy as
normal doing his thing and well slinking
about and so we going to keep following
him he looks as though he's might be a
bit hungry actually
he was quite funny because he walked
along this so the edge of chaos time we
saw his tracks and Steve said had we got
any luck and I said no this tracks yeah
but I don't see any sign of him and then
figure said no but there he is right
next to us so he was just walking along
right next to kind of parallel with us
and it's now just crossed over the damn
wall a tree are sitting and watching
what's going on and as he was walking
along there was a bird that made a bit
of a noise and he just crawled it see
you said no don't shout at me
I'm I'm just merely walking and so he
seems as though he's probably somehow
spotted something over the dam or what
she's very interested in you can see
he's kind of what this face that's
staring in that direction his tails
twitching a little bit as well so I'm
hoping that for his case that there's
maybe a little Stian book or a dike oh
that's around that he's deciding whether
or not he's going to hunt now it's a bit
of deja vu to have husana Beckett
treehouse dammit we've spoken it about
us a lot that this was his favorite
haunt last J used to spend a lot of time
here hunting and doing his thing so it's
nice to actually have him here in this
area again I just hope that he's not
spreading his wings too much he needs to
go back towards the pan so that we don't
see him disappearing a south and west I
know it's selfish but we want him all
for ourselves here on Jimmer we don't
want him to go further afield where we
can't see him anymore because I quite
like having him around these days hello
love when he does that he doesn't often
way he's just walking and doesn't kind
of break stride he just kind of starts
grooming himself as he goes now when I
keep up with him because he will
disappear fairly quickly and we know
he's an active boy so Kimberly you say
oh hello husana it's so lovely to see
you again yes it is lovely to see him
isn't it I mean he's a fairly regular
feature these days in fact I would like
to know how many drives we've actually
had husana on drive since he arrived
back it would be very interesting to me
to know how many times he's appeared
since he's arrived back and how many
drives we've actually seen him I know
there's been one or two where we haven't
seen him at all but for the most part
we've almost seen him every single Drive
which has been
quite phenomenal it's it's not every day
that you're going to get a leopard like
this I mean even a female leopard with
Cubs we know with tandy we used to go
quite a few days without finding her
sometimes
and yet husana we somehow managed every
day he seems to kind of grace us with
his presence and I say he Grace's us
with his presence because a lot of the
time he kind of appears rather than us
actually finding no Catherine I don't
think so I mean I don't think he comes
out to me I mean James has had some a
lot of sightings of him so Steven many
of the sightings I've had have been you
know thanks to everyone at watching the
dam camp that has has shown him to us
and told us about that he's there so
it's not really for me that I mean I
guess we have you know it's quite easy
and that I can just go to certain places
and know that he's going to be roughly
in those areas and then from you know
try and track him down from there but I
don't think he necessarily gravitates
towards me any more than he gravitates
towards any of the other cars or guides
or anything like that most people would
be able to find him quite regularly I
think I don't know maybe who knows with
these things
animals are quite something sometimes
and particularly this one Paulina's just
the excitement it's it's much like
salivation it's much like us when we get
it's kind of sweaty when we get it you
know and when the adrenaline starts to
to go through there might start to pump
through the body you know we start to
have sweaty hands or something like that
so I think for them it's more just a
case that they've seen something in this
their bodies almost reaction and you'll
probably find that a lot of the females
have that twitching tail in order to
tell the Cubs you stop there you mustn't
move because I'm now hunting so it's
almost a signal to the Cubs that hang on
there's something up here in front that
I need to investigate the cub can then
stop and maybe that's in learned
behavior that then carries through even
into the males as they go through life
they see their mom's tail twitching so
much that they learn from it but I mean
it's it's it's pretty much just a body
response to something that makes them
excited there's probably a rush of
adrenaline and that's just part of the
twitch that they get when they start to
think and start to kind of express some
sort of emotion now I wonder where he's
going at the moment it it's
amazes me how every time we kind of find
him
he's generally not doing too much and
then we start to walk with him and he
almost starts to find him and then he
starts to walk and to say all right guys
we've been waiting for you all day it's
time to go through a bit of a walk time
to go and see what I can explore and
what I can find which is quite fine by
me I quite enjoy having an active asana
it's always nice to be up and about with
him as we go it's part of the reason why
many of us enjoy following him is
because he is not the most you know
sleepy cat his dad is far sleepier than
what he is the thing is with him though
is he will get there eventually he will
as he becomes more dominant and older so
his youthfulness will run out and you'll
start to probably sleep more and miss
around and walk around less I hope that
it doesn't change it would be nice if he
didn't ever change but and you know most
men lipids tend to go that way right for
sauna where you going to go you're going
to go to the big mound in front of you I
don't know I think you might go into the
drainage line here and maybe just find a
nice spot to sit for a while before he
contemplates his next move still a bit
early in the day for him to be hunting
so I would imagine that he's you know
kind of just looking around and just
trying to see somewhere where he can
take a bit of a rest for now I mean or
maybe hunt a little bit later in the
evening but he's just stopped again so
let's carry on there Fergus let's try
getting the goose up
right now while we head off in this
direction and try and get into a better
position to see little Hosanna that send
you back across to Steve and see if he's
had any luck it's with well
Dingaan his dad Hassan is dead well
thank you Justin if anyone was going to
find a silo to be you but if anyone was
going to find her son have to be you and
I bet you he waited for you to find him
and then he started moving
that is what husana likes to do yeah the
first animal that we have seen this
afternoon so we're going to show you him
through a little bit of a thicket well
the interesting for finding or sana I'm
sure you're not upset that if we see him
every single day doesn't get boring he
is an absolutely marvelous individual
and the reason why Impala hang out and
herds like this is because they are
leopards around and they're safe to be
in numbers even though the dry season is
upon us the vegetation is lacking a lot
of it's sort of nutrients it still pays
to be in a herd because it's a bit
selfish ready you kind of stand in the
middle and hopefully one of the guys on
the outside gets taken and when we watch
the leopards hunting it's quite
interesting to see that the larger the
herds that they have the large the herd
is the less chance there is of a leopard
actually catching one of them Nikita you
wouldn't know if Impala are born without
a cent well I'm not 100% sure about in
part I think it's possible that the baby
impalas are lots of small antelope for
lots of babies when they're born are
completely scentless which is quite
interesting and they often get hidden in
the long grass away from the prying eyes
of predators but Impala I think they
don't have a scent when they're born I'm
not homosexual but Impala no water buck
and a couple others don't have any smell
but what impala do quite early on is a
little nursery groups you'll find one or
two females hanging around with with a
herd of 3040 little youngsters it's the
cutest thing ever and that you see that
time of year you see baby in parlour
getting munched on
like candy by all the Predators and you
think that that makes a huge dent in the
population but almost what 25 30 % of
the population breeds so it's an
enormous increase in babies at one time
and yes a lot of them do die and get fed
upon but so many survive and that's why
well that strategy is why Impala are so
successful there are all a little bit
alert you can see the lone bull a hurt
Apple the lone ram in the middle of it
he still thinks there's some breeding
females around as he herds them together
the rut
the second rut seemingly fully underway
we heard quite a few noises this morning
it's nowhere near as vigorous as it has
been you can see how wide leaves
displayed his horns are is a magnificent
specimen yeah they're sort of start
pointing out at the top hello Roslyn do
you know how big the horn is hmm I'm not
sure I've never measured the horns it's
not something I'm too familiar with
whole length but that's tooth would you
say Craig you good with measurements 18
inches 16 inches I really don't know
Roseland I'm sorry I need to go and have
a look up and find out horn lengths but
maybe and I'm pretty sure one of the
viewers out there will be able to
hashtag Safari larvae let us know how
long in palo impala horns are and
interestingly enough as well the impala
up in the mara have got even bigger
horns see he's having a little bit of a
sniff he's trying to find some female
she looks a little bit pregnant though
doesn't she a little bit round on the
belly you can see that the the browsing
animals start to to lose a little bit of
condition on their hips the hips start
to stand out but you can still see that
the Bailey's quite round if if they were
not pregnant the belly would be quite
skinny you see it on the young males and
the young females is a young female
there she doesn't look to have the same
sort of belly does she look at her
oops see she's definitely not pregnant
she might even be too old she doesn't
look a little bit old but you can see
how the condition is starting to wane on
them the dry season the rain we had last
night is only the beginning
but sometimes it's just a bit of a tease
for the animals it's just a cold day or
two the little little bit of a light
spattering of rain but not really
providing them with what they need but I
have no doubts with the amount too moist
we had it's going to be a little bit of
a flash which is gonna really benefit
these animals because they are extremely
selective feeders and we'll choose the
best nourishment in and around in the
savanna okay well then we gonna go over
to Tristan and his little chief who is
moving let's see what his plans are well
see now he is busy moving away from us
quite quickly he was kind of lurking
about a termite mound here seems as I
was watching something on the other side
of the mound and then kind of got to the
top of it looked and then decided now
I'm not interested and carried on going
so don't know what it was I think
there's some Franklin's that are shot in
here maybe is watching them walking
along you can actually see his tails
gone up now as he moves off but it's
interesting to kind of think where he's
kind of going and what he's up to and to
answer the question about the Impala
horns I know that generally in parlor
horns are around so Steve wasn't far off
they reckon they're normally between 18
and 20 inches that's a good size for a
set of Impala horns the good news is
that the son of the way he's walking
he's just going straight back to the pan
and if he carries on the route that he's
going it's the opposite of what I
followed him the other day when he meets
up with Dingaan are we kind of going
that opposite way and it's almost back
towards where his pan is and his little
hassanis haunt and that's where he's
kind of hitting now seeing hasana today
is I suppose in many respects quite
bittersweet and I'll tell you that wine
shortly because a year ago today it was
a day very similar to this the sun was
shining it was a bit cold actually I
remember it being quite chilly and we
hadn't seen her sauna for quite some
time actually we hadn't seen him at all
with Shaun Gillett and we went to Galago
pan and the two of them were lying right
at the pan together for the first time
in quite a while I think we had seen her
sauna a little bit but we hadn't seen
much of them together at all and it was
the first time that we'd seen the two
lying together for quite a long period
and it was a joyous occasion because
well you know anytime you get to see
those two together was always quite fun
and it was so nice and sweet just to
watch the two of them go about their
thing now I'm going to try and catch up
with him quickly um and you know he
spent that whole afternoon with him and
then as the Sun started to sits so
arrived
Tandi and it was the first time that
Andy had really kind of asserted herself
as the new sort of ruler of this area
and the new dominant female and she went
after shangela and there's a massive
fight that ensued as we all know and we
had this kind of whole process that
played out and in tumble was seen in the
area and ting gana was heard that night
coming into that section and calling and
so there's all these leopards around and
the fight carried on until I mean the
last time I heard them fighting is at
about 10:30 that night which is I
suppose it's quite late into the night
and that was the last time we saw some
Healy I'm afraid which was quite sad
than a year ago today was the last time
that we saw her she was such a beautiful
little leopard and I say was I mean in
terms of us seeing her you know she
could still be alive somewhere in Kruger
and I hope that she is I mean it's it's
obviously something that we've discussed
at length
many many times as to her whereabouts
whether she's dead with it she's alive
and you know everyone's got their own
theories and opinions and it runs
entitled to that and everyone's got
their own kind of thought processes but
for me realistically I don't think that
she's still with us and just because she
was so relaxed and and could have been
somewhere I mean she would have been
seen somewhere going towards Kruger but
the part of me hopes that I'm very very
wrong then that she does appear
somewhere in the sort of random parts of
Kruger where somebody sees her and she
misses as beautiful Lepidus with her own
Cubs in her own family that's what I
really want and our this is one case
where I really do want to be proved
wrong but I just you know knowing how
she was and how relaxed she was and that
she never was seen again in this area
would tell me that it's a one fight like
that wouldn't have asked her and exiled
her to the point where nobody ever saw
her again or any
around us and she was too relaxed for
her to go to another place and no one to
find her so he has a difficult thing
that's an you know horrible to kind of
think about that if she did maybe
sustain injuries there that could have
led to her demise
I don't think Tandy killed her I didn't
do you want to make that point very
clear I don't think Tandy killed her and
a toe or anything silly like that I
think but I definitely think it's very
possible that she got injured badly
enough that she couldn't find food for
herself with who defend herself against
maybe other predators and that's maybe
what links led to demise it is also you
never know I mean there's too many
variables with five lipids in the same
citing as to what could have happened I
mean turned he could have thoughts
tambour was at risk
Tandy could have you know ting gana
could have come in in the confusion
attacked the wrong female you know you
never know what could have happened in
that particularly evening and what led
to her kind of disappearing but I I do
hope that she's alive somewhere with my
kind of brain says that probably not
Scirocco you say that you hope that
she's happy somewhere in Kruger your
heart has hopes that she's happy in
Kruger I think everyone does I think all
of us hope that she's some ways she's
like if she is some way and she is get
does get seen one day there's going to
be a very special cat that somebody is
going to have the pleasure of actually
viewing and now would have been so nice
had she stayed in this area it would
have been amazing to watch the
progression alongside of us on earth to
see how well he's done if she had been
the same it would have been a very
spectacular kind of way to have since
well to kind of keep screwless memory
alive in many respects because you know
angular was the last daughter and we
know that tiny while she's amazing and
she's very cool she's she's an older
female and so her lineage and her line
is not the only kind of carrying forward
components of the of the corolla LED
line so it would've been nice just to
have had another female around and just
seemed that canudas females all had bad
luck it was you know she really battled
a lot too other than Tandy and shadow
and you know obviously shadows not
around but the rest kind of just seemed
to disappear into obscurity
unfortunately in the form of Shivan Xion
in obviously sure
you live you know let's think of good
things about you actually might be a
good time to ask what or your favorite
memory of shangri-la is hashtag Safari
live what's your favorite memory was
anyway in the meantime we'll keep
following him and we'll send you back
over to the Masai Mara to David who I'm
sure would have loved to have spent time
with little Zhong Yi Lin well thank you
to stern and I hope you will be or you
let us know at one point the fate of
Shambhala and you got a big L here a big
boy huge bull by any standard and I'm
not sure it was Steve over who was
talking earlier about the impalas in the
Mara and he thought to the impalas in
the Mara got bigger Rock of Hans than
the ones in South Africa and for
elephants also I'd want to see the boys
here the mills tend to be slightly bit
big in size and the ones here in South
Africa I could be wrong but I might have
picked up the Murcia being rather huge
in size maybe not by much but slightly a
bit bigger than the males in the Kruger
National Park so this big male who was
turning towards us earlier and now he's
just giving us his back moving to a
different direction but I've always
wondered look at the elephants you
always see they could very wrinkled
skins and I've been trying to think all
my life I have only had one argument
that the wrinkled skin increases the
surface area and by having a larger
surface area that gives them better
chances of cooling off because they've
always seen of flapping their ears to
cool off but I think the wrinkled skin
they got makes the surface area to be
much bigger and in the process they're
able to lose much heat and I don't know
what happened when it's cold they tend
to have their skin not as wrinkled and
not having as many spaces between the
skins just not you know to look very big
so I got another car just passing next
to us and they just enjoying the drive
like us us we move away and our Eddy has
gone and you're gonna be looking for
something else in a few seconds already
okay I want to turn around I have seen
some giraffe from a distance from where
I am and that's where I want to go now
so just hold you know for a minute
what you think our elephant is too far
from here
what do you think of that she's now kind
of come unlike a Lea think you out he's
not just thank you very much
he kept moving and moving
sorry Megan what did Bob rascal has
increased or decreased in Amara
very good Barbara and I would tell you
tourism in Amara has increased and my
own research have told me tours you
might have increased by a whole 10
percent this is what we call our peak
season and our peak season is always the
months of June July and sometimes early
September and since we have been doing
what we're doing now and I'm talking
about safari like what we do
showing you Barbara and many other
viewers it's wonderful wildlife that you
have here my own research have told me
the numbers of tourism or the number of
tourists in this country has gone high I
personally think what we have drew what
you're doing now have opened many
people's eyes Barbara and I've saved for
a fox the number of tourists have
improved or has gone higher the other
day we are very lucky Barbara's a move
on we were visited in our final control
by the permanent secretary or the
cabinet secretary in tourism and we had
a great time with him and was so good
and was very happy to see what we do and
as he left he concurred with us that we
have brought a lot of changes in this
country in terms of tourism all right
we're gonna keep moving I can see some
primates from a distance what I call
baboons and the particular bones we have
in this part of East Africa we couldn't
they only baboons we got two species of
baboons in East Africa we got the olive
baboons and we got the yellow baboons
what I can see here I'm trying to bounce
our chat but we are making sure he
doesn't slip but you can see ahead of me
are what we call the yellow the booms I
mean they Oliver bones is quite a big
troop it has big males I can tell from
the size females young ones and you will
find out what they're feeding on here
because baboons just like human beings
are omnivores gross and both meats
cannabis they'll be going for
grasshoppers crickets an insect they can
get their would be also be going for
rabbits scrub hairs anything they can
get I've seen some of them even going
for phones or you know lumps of
antelopes and tell me Archie's it's a
good angle here all right I just hop in
there and take us all the way to those
early baboons and a mixed group that's a
big boy there look at on a cove that
still there swing down and would you
wanna dip there sometimes they'll dig
for tubers or some roots from the grass
Oh
sometimes the D guam's and Megan in the
final controls is that's so cool
because I found out in South Africa we
got totally different species of baboons
that's called chuckman which I only saw
them there I had never seen them before
so we took over the chochmah and here
we'll be talking of the oliver wounds
and also the yellow baboons teeny-tiny
young one there and I think with the
mother and they'll always land very
quickly so I'll pick some seeds from the
grass are you big enough to feed
yourself are you just playing with logs
and sticks
you should be fitting and what they do
sometimes when they move logs like that
they turn the logs and they find some
warmth of some insect under them or some
termites
anything would be under there they're
very clever primates I would say and
I've always seen some very cheeky ones
if they turn the log or a bowl or a
stone and they find they've got some
warmth Oh some insect lying there and
they're the big bubbles will come close
by they just put the rock or the stone
down and then they sit on it and they
start scratching themselves until all
the baboons have gone and then they turn
it over again and they start eating
how beautiful
sorry Megan what the coffee kiosk I'll
say keep moving train getting closer to
them sorry Megan I missed that question
great question there can be bones use
sticks as tools as we go back to these
buffoons here I have not seen the boots
exactly doing that would have seen their
cousins that's out call the gorillas
sorry about that jerky I've seen
gorillas and chimpanzees using sticks as
tools and they've been known to dig on
the ground for food but the boots have
not seen them doing that what I found or
would have seen the baboon's do is
getting say a piece of grass a long
stalk of grass and going to atomic mound
and pushing it right through the hole of
a tumin mound and when the soldiers for
example think they're being attacked by
someone they come and they start biting
that piece of grass and then the baboons
just pull up the piece of grass and they
start feeding on the termites that I've
seen baboons doing and more so these
ones we are seeing here the only of
baboons but I have not seen them using
sticks to dig
and either way the very clever primate
and you can tell she is either doing
something from the grass there and as I
said either going for roots or for
tumors but in the meantime we got
antelopes in South Africa that love
staying very close to water
yes well sorry we had some water back
that we're drinking and have now moved
back off into the thickets we were at
perfil circle watering hole we've got
two very nice-looking fork-tailed
drongos that have been dive-bombing into
the water and now they're giving
themselves a proper little wash
here we go isn't that fantastic very
very wet they've flown into the water
gotten very very wet and then flown back
to very inaccessible bush not close to
the water quite close to the water's
edge where they can preen and clean get
the dust out get the parasites out and
basically just to make themselves look
very very good for the upcoming week
that is approaching and it's possible
that also the little bit of rainfall we
had yesterday just got all the feathers
out of joint and they weren't really
able to dry themselves so they get that
sort of that musty sort of smell you
know that damp smell so now they're able
to go and shake all the the dirt out and
all the water out and probably then
they'll reprieve themselves they're
zipping all of the feathers back into
place a little bit of a shake you know
wish I could do that with my body here
we go
oh one just down bombed again did he see
very good dive bombing Forktail drongos
that's awesome
obviously that I want to submerge
themselves because they might find it
difficult to get out so they're
basically just hitting their chests on
the water trying not to get their wings
too wet and then they're moving that
moisture through their body to
distribute it through all of the
feathers and shake themselves around
okay well these Forktail drummers are
gonna keep doing their bathing duties
asked this afternoon let's go over to
Tristan who thinks got a fantastic view
of the little chief well we do have a
fantastic view I don't know if you can
see him but right above my head right
there Israel Hassan is sitting so he's
just taking it very easy right next to
us at the moment we parked in he was far
away and he just wandered along and it's
not just sitting here and I'm waiting
for a scroll that's about to start a
long calling it in because there's a
scroll not too far from where he
currently is at the moment that is going
to make a bit of a noise as soon as he
steps onto the road but he's just kind
of weighing up his options the problem
is he's turned quite far south now so
he's going pretty much southwards
towards twin dams area instead of going
northwards to his pan which is naughty
hasana you're not allowed to go south
you know that little Gary's out of
bounds these days you have to be a Juma
cat from now on now let's see he's going
straight to the yeast now which is
supposed to better than where he was
going a little bit earlier but hopefully
doesn't go into the strange because
it'll be very difficult to follow him so
Koren I'm not sure let's suppose it's
possible that he knows his name given
that you know it's hid so much around
him I doubt it though I mean you yeah I
say Hasani he doesn't really look at me
most of the time if I say if I Sanne and
sometimes I find myself I know I
shouldn't but I find myself talking to
him quite often when we're all fate just
driving around it's not something you
should do with a wild animal because
they're not gonna listen to you nor are
they your pits but it's just one of
those things that happens I'm afraid but
he doesn't respond he doesn't really
look at us I mean every now and then
you'll kind of glance over his shoulder
if you talking an easy
kind of walks past but he doesn't seem
to be too kind of concerned about the
whole thing and definite he doesn't seem
to be too worried about his name so I
don't think so I mean I think he can
recognize voices but I don't think he
has had any reason to recognize a name
you know a lot of the theories of why
dogs and things recognize their names is
because they this kind of reward at the
end of it they get called and in this
food reward and those kind of things
which there isn't with husana and so I
don't think that he actually I mean I
might be wrong maybe he does maybe I'm
not giving him enough credit I'm sorry
I'm sorry if that is the case I do
apologize now I believe a lots of you
have been commenting about shangela and
your favorite kind of memories of him
and most a lot of you are saying the
bush walks well the bush walks I think
were the favorite memories of probably
90% of the safari light guides I know
that brains
Jamie James they had some incredible
experiences with shangilia husana that
far more than you know what I did or
even Taylor or you know obviously Scott
didn't actually mention given and Steven
Ralph neither but you know the James and
and Jamie and and Brent really did spend
a lot of time with him and I know when I
talk to any of them about showing either
that they always think about her fondly
as this bush war cat that was just the
most kind of amazing creature to spend
time with on foot and you know she was
she was incredible I luckily got on Bush
walked twice not for very long periods
of time but I didn't get to see her
twice on Bush walk now he was gonna pull
up alongside hasanat because he's now
posing right next to us at the same
height as us which is always very very
pleasant with him but you know it's she
was an incredible incredible animal and
she her tolerance on walks was in insane
so for those of you don't know who
shangilia is she was horse Ana's sister
from the lipid that we're looking at at
the moment and she disappeared like I
said a year ago and and she had an
incredibly relaxed nature with us on
foot and so he did a lot of Bush walks
where we used to track her in husana
when they were still Cubs when they were
under you know Corollas care and
protection and she just had this
tolerance for people on foot server and
far more than what husana does I mean
husana was pretty relaxed but she was
just on another level and she would
allow
as to sit very close to her and she
would just go about her business and
wouldn't care that's all we've had I'm
sure it would have changed as she became
a mother and became more territorial but
for that period it was just unbelievable
to watch her as she went about her
business it was a very special thing to
be a part of so that was amazing and I'm
not surprised that a lot of you remember
her as the bushwalk cat she was very
very cool what are you doing lisanna
sniffing quite a bit in the air now the
air the wind is blowing kind of from his
left to right at the moment and so I
wonder if there's maybe just something
that he's caught on the breeze anyway
while we sit with him and think about
ash angular a little bit more let's send
you back across to David in the Mara and
see what he's got for us now you never
know husana was a very smart leopard and
as I left South Africa he was my
favorite followed by the Duke king Ghana
but the only one thing I can't remember
is where I ever saw a leopard going for
a fully grown ostrich and we got the
Masai ostrich there on your frame and
please remember keep asking us as many
questions as you'd like your questions
gives us a lot of joy any comment that
should want to make or such a beautiful
bird like this ostrich here which I want
to believe it could be the largest bird
in the world I could be wrong but I
would wish just compare it to the emails
in Australia but I think in Africa this
is our largest bad a couple of months
they got a question from a video ask me
which is the largest but in a wild David
Oh in Africa sorry and I say the Pelican
I don't know where my head was
but I was just thinking of maybe the
highest flying you know the heaviest
flying birds a lot of a pelican but also
we got busters which are equally heavy
but and then I started thinking of
albatross which you don't have in Africa
and then I forgot the ostrich well very
clear dimorphism very clear sexual
dimorphism in the ostriches
and this is definitely a male I'm sure
we all know black and white Linda how
are you and you're saying this is the
forest or Street you've seen on safari
life I do not know whether you've been
always there but I'm equally excited
cause his Saturn's being live in Amara I
don't think I've seen Linda any ostrich
this is the first one and I just or not
you know what I'm so excited it's an
ostrich the way Tristan gets excited
seeing husana oh you know someone else
seeing the Lions
I saw the ostrich and I was like wow an
ostrich
so again is a saying this is a male
ostrich as you can see it's black and
white all the feathers and red legs and
neck if you see the females I'm sure we
know femurs are always great in color
and like any other bad feeling on seeds
from the grass it which definitely picks
an insect there it reserves
pick it up
Pauline how are you and that is an
interesting question I can tell you
ostriches do not fly and you know you
are so saying Hawaii do they have wings
and through evolution I don't think they
have ever been able to fly but the fact
that they don't fly Pauline they'll get
exactly what they need because if they
can feed themselves well without flying
one two they can defend themselves
without flying because I would say
Pauline the flying in many birds will
always aid them to get away from their
would-be predators for example you get
doves being attacked by Falcons and what
they would do is just fly and taking off
an ostrich will not fly but ostriches
Pauline I've seen them I'm sure you know
the very very fast boss just like
cheetahs and they will just fly low and
if Conan Pauline and not Street should
kick and kick very hard but also using
the big if you look at that big bear
they have been known to poke eyes out of
either hyenas or you know would-be
predators like lions so I would say I
have never known them flying and they'll
have wings maybe once in a while you see
them flapping their wings and especially
during the mating dance when you see
ostriches you know doing some courtship
dance you will see them dropping their
wings and just you know moving them up
and down and that's the only would say
they would have the wings I don't see
any other reason why Pauline or how they
use the wings for any other reason
because they don't fly but the village
where I come from we have always said
that ostriches are very clever birds and
if those see fire somewhere though drum
there and especially if they have eggs
hatchlings or smaller chicks with them
the drum there and using the wings they
would beat and kill the fire hopefully
we see that at one point Pauline it'll
be interesting but that's could be the
only thing I'd say a reason say
ostriches got wings as you go back to it
for another one quick look I mean it's
wonderful just to see an ostrich in the
savanna rather see how it turns out
beautifully looking
and almost everything of an ostrich goes
to good use nothing's wasted I mean we
got ostrich farms all over the world and
the feathers or rather the bones of
ostriches have been claimed to be solid
and you got locos like in Africa make
even jelly rhythm
of course they pull all the droppings of
ostriches very good fertilizer and it
has also been claimed that some feathers
of ostrich I don't know what part of the
feather on which feathers I have got
some electromagnetic you know effect on
them and back in the village I would
remember if someone would come
complaining I got something in my eye
that it cannot come out you wash your
eye you splash your eye with water you
still feel the smaller pecker it
and you tend to think it could be a
piece of metal
I would heap you saying can you get an
ostrich feather and that used to work
magic and that you know explains most
likely ostriches maybe have
electromagnetic on their feathers
achieve you come to me here I want us to
look in show Pauline and all the other
viewers the differences between the
males and females would have been
watching right down there and right
there
Thank You Archie that is the Miller you
can see the black and white there and
apparently the one that we have on the
screen there if you could the legs they
are more pink than this and this that's
what we call the breeding plumage and
maybe he was a little colorful like that
and the guards might come around her and
now we're going to go to the ostrich the
female look at the ostrich female
they're very different brownish in color
gray not very bright the legs and necks
don't get pink but an interesting point
here pulling and all the other nice
viewers when you look at the chicks
they're down there when they are all
young both males and females they have
the same color but at a particular age
for five six months as they get older
that's not when you see in males coming
to almost looking defense from the
females already we're going to
now and Thank You ostrich hopefully
we're gonna see the guys around here I
haven't seen the females but you see the
male ok moving on yes don't keep don't
forget to keep sending questions through
hashtag Safari lame as usual anything
you'd want to know any comments you'd
want to make like Pauline that was fun
Tasi well Tristan lets us know what
Hasani is up to now well we are still
busy with hasanah he posed for us
beautifully on a man for a few minutes
before deciding to carry on again and is
now walking straight north he listened
to us he's going north directly towards
where we want him to go and so I'm
pretty sure who ever is watching damn
can this evening at some point he will
appear tonight I think it's kind of
hitting in that direction it's gonna
take him a long time to get these quite
far south then he normally is but he is
going slowly in that direction now we
were discussing shangilia and I believe
a lot of you have been carrying on
sending your memories and it's always
such a nice thing to go down memory lane
and sometimes and just kind of remember
all of these great sightings and many of
you are talking about her proficiency at
Terrapin hunting the hasana and her both
went through that phase for quite some
time where they would go after every
Terrapin that moved as well as monitor
lizards does anyone remember the monitor
lizard sighting at the dam when gari dam
had water in it and not dry like it is
now and she grabbed that before monitor
lizard I think it was with brink if I'm
not mistaken that she had that's that
was pretty incredible I've thoroughly
enjoyed that sighting actually because
she and I've showed quite a lot of
prowess and I was the first major thing
that we saw her chase I if I remember
correctly you know besides Terrapin so
it was actually something that actively
moved that she was able to get and to
bring down so kind of secure I don't
know bring down is probably the right
word but she was able to secure it as a
meal so that was very very cool what
else
even lots of you're commenting to the
fact that she stood up to tiny so
efficiently
what she did I would that was probably
the most shocking thing about that
sighting
that site seemed like it was yesterday I
thought about its a lot over the lot of
course of the last few weeks and
personna what are you doing boy it's
hard not to like this cats now he's
playing with the log in his scratching
his cause and there he goes he's just
running off now but um I remember that
sighting very clearly because she you
know she went from she was a small girl
should make no mistake that Sangeeta was
a tiny little leopard when she had that
fight with tandy and she was way out
cross bite and even by his experience
weight size everything like that so she
really did not have it easy at all but
she stood up to Tandy and she really did
fight for her her life so to speak and
she was incredibly good at defending
ourselves she really did defend herself
very well and I was surprised I mean in
fact she got a few blows to Tandy Tandy
ended up with a few claw marks on her
face I think tiny was taken aback
slightly in the first encounter and then
maybe just as the night 110g realized
that she was just that much more
superior and that much more kind of
physically more stronger than what Chung
Keeler was and maybe that's was kind of
you know her approaches in her Bolton's
got more towards Sheila but it wasn't
pretty incredible her ability to to
stand up to that cat and to really make
herself feel like well make us feel like
she had a chance and then she is she
stood up to herself with aplomb the
amazing part about that for me was the
way that's husana also reacted in that
he came back and basically just sat
right next to his sister even when time
he was growling and hissing it would
have been easy for him just to run away
Tandy wouldn't have chased him in any
way whatsoever because well he was not
her two targets it's amazing what's our
Tammy realized who the target was in
that whole thing and you know he's still
sat with her and they kind of stayed
together and he followed everyone around
and it must be such a confusing time for
him too because he didn't really know
what was going on there was this cat
that was kinda related to him it's
chasing his sister must have been very
very difficult for poor little husana at
that point but he also too was a showed
amazing kind of display for a leopard in
that he really kind of went to his
sister's side and just sat there and sat
with the three
onslaught that she received from tandy
very special cats indeed and you notice
we sadly then see these cats grow up and
become these adult females now we are
going to go through what can only be
described as possibly the worst part of
Jummah which is this monkey orange to
the kids and I need to find a way
through this
so while I do that I'm gonna send you
off to Steve so that he can relieve us
of our duties while we try and tackle
this mess well good luck tristin getting
through the thickets we have found a
little Co V of Franklin's little crested
Franklin with a white super silly man
coming down the back of the I the dark
beak in the orangey pink legs they are
very camouflaged in the in the grass and
they are walking around picking whatever
grass seeds might be left scratching
through the dung of elephant and Buffalo
we have not far away from Buffalo
watering hole Nass a fair amount of
Buffalo and elephant come down providing
and bringing all of the nutrients
through which then provide insects and
also seeds for birds like this and
without those large moving animals
probably would be not too much food
available and do provide a lot of their
food camouflage the reason we stopped is
this very important important to stop
from time to time and just to listen not
so long ago Craig and I did the mist
medicinal Monday we were to treat just
over thee and ten Ghana there was lying
on this termite mound watching us for a
while and after we turned around and
came back we found him and we were only
about fifty meters away I think he's
quite interested in that discussion I
had that day on the morula it was a good
one hey Craig was it good one Craig's
not nodding his head even though he
didn't taste any of the liquids that I
made he was happy to eat the nuts but he
wasn't happy to eat to try any of the
liquid I think the guys I work with
think I'm a little bit mad and they also
been scared of some of the things I
create
ah makes doesn't think I'm mad thanks
max max can you say that question again
please I'm sorry
from Cal six this sounds like a good
question yes
Cal six you're not about quails okay we
do have a few quails let me show you
quickly just gonna wipe my screen I'm
sorry it gets a little bit a little bit
dirty okay let me just quickly open it
up we get little button quails those are
the most common ones that we that we
find you don't often actually see them
let me just spell it correctly
Hottentot button quail and the Kerry
Cain button quail let me go to bird
family here we get a number of the small
I can't see the screen here Craig er
how's that view yeah sorry about the
fingerprint let me just give it one more
wipe everything is so dusty at this time
of year okay so at the top we've got the
Harlequin quail I don't think we get
them yet the blue quail is not yeah the
Hottentot down at the bottom with the
Karachay and these two little these two
little guys here you do get them in the
area and the common quail as well and
they all make very strange noises it me
play the the Karachay and quail for you
quickly we have to play through my hat
hello
but mournful isn't it that's all you get
to hear of it it's just as very mournful
sort of sort of call and in the
Hottentot oh and says the daughter is
missing that's strange
maybe doesn't call no I'm sure I've
heard it call before anyway yeah there's
a couple that you get to common the
Hottentot and the the carrot chain are
definitely ones that you will find in
Iran and the low felt the others I
haven't seen myself personally but
they're very hard to come by they'll
hide in the long grass there and
sometimes they scare the life out of you
when you're walking because as you walk
in there just pop explode out of the
long grass but we don't farm quails or
anything like that in and around this
area see this is the tree that we were
that we were looking at that one day not
far at all from where mr. ting gana
himself was watching us
no signs of him at all in this afternoon
and we've been checking quite
deliberately on the ground but after a
little bit of rain and with vehicles
driving it's really difficult sometimes
to get tracks unless there's a bit of a
sandy sort of area the soil actually
gets quite hard it gets a little bit
tougher and actually need a little bit
more sort of disturbance on it to to
open that track up but we're gonna keep
trying I'm gonna be going down
drakensberg Road towards the south and
see if we can finally mean they mean
something let's go back up to mr.
Guiteau who's on the road
well steep well done
hopefully you'll be lucky let us know
how it goes they know you such a good
talker
especially when you always jump out of
the car and you look at the trucks all
these cuts and I want to show you
something that I think when leopards do
bring one down
it's always something very massive and
we want to introduce you now to an
antelope that take all the topi big big
topi there and of all the big prey I've
known thank you very much and Megan see
it's very nice from the finer control
leopards in general could be anything 35
40 kilos for the females some males 70
75 kilos this guy you see here could be
a hundred plus kilos in weight almost
200 pounds but I have once the whole
thing huge mela pots maybe likes over
Tinga Tinga is a very big male leopard
in South Africa in Duma private game
reserve but I've seen the big leopards
here also in the Mara triangle bringing
down big and swaps like this and again
this is what I call the choppy and this
antelope is very similar to what you
call accessable in South Africa Kuantan
are picked in the tapas if actually are
going to get hold of that here and make
sure the ear doesn't move and look at
the pattern of that here this reminds me
of watered calls
who the Steinbach sorry that's slopping
they're very very noisy either she might
be having some eggs around here and look
at the beauty of that ear I've always
loved the patent on the inner side of
the ear it as usual
yeah towers getting the Flyers out the
colors of these animals are very
interesting is one animal you see a
combination of different colors the
brown the grayish the black and I would
say maybe that aids them to blend in
away from their would-be predators temps
have a break so they'll always you know
grab as much grass as they can then this
pose joy how are you and a squirrel
question man there I would say yes so we
see the [ __ ] harvester here I would say
almost the same family with the tapas
and we see them here and they don't have
the same colors this they tend to have
one brown color they don't have the
mixed colors joy so we do see the [ __ ]
harvest here and then different types of
the harvest and the [ __ ] hospice if you
look at the Thomson gazelle such a much
smaller than [ __ ] harvest I'll say
going in the next size of Teddy Thompson
gazelles the [ __ ] harvest and the
Fosters I would say antelopes we got
around here so many times you see the
[ __ ] a twist together with a trapeze
and strange just to see him alone there
eating you might see one top like that
but Joanne look at the [ __ ] harvest in
general in general they'll be moving in
a small yard anything from five to ten
but to see one tapa like that it's very
normal
all right choppy keep eating and make
sure you don't get any leopards coming
close to you and we're gonna move
forward and look for more beautiful
animals okay
from a distance I can see some zebras
coming up hopefully they will say where
they are and we're gonna enjoy watching
zebras this is a great day today alia
was talking about rumination with there
they are with the Buffaloes and there's
a view who asked me that question and I
gotta be telling you more on the
rumination and when I looked rumination
with us human beings but asana could be
on the move maybe yes maybe not Tristan
well he is on the move at the moment
he's hunting water so he's seen a group
of warthogs that he's not chasing which
is the first time I've seen him chase
warthogs yet so I haven't seen him go
after warthogs very much and he's not
very skilled at it but there are the
warthogs are here and him and warthogs
are straight ahead and then he's just
watching them as they're kind of moving
away from him a little bit so he's just
kind of weighing up his options and
trying to kind of pick it up and see
where exactly he's gonna position
himself I think he's a little light
probably for the warthogs that we just
saw now both of those warthogs look
quite big but let's just see how he goes
about it it's going to be something that
he will hunt a lot when he gets a little
bit bigger and a bit older we know male
they pit stint ever a taste for warthogs
husana hasn't shown that yet but I
wonder if maybe this year now when we
have the piglets season and the kind of
breeding season for warthogs if it's not
going to be something high up on his
menu and something he's gonna start
learning to actually go after a dirty
old pass up the opportunity to hunt
little piglets it's a perfect size snack
for him so I'm pretty sure that he will
do it what I'm gonna try to do those I
want to try get on to the road area so
we're not clattering about and
off-roading while he's trying to hunt he
is heading towards the road and the
warthogs ran towards the road too so I
want to just try and get into that area
before it becomes an issue now careful
there Fergal is a very horrible Buffalo
thorn that is not going to be pleasant
ideally
[Music]
this direction but to be going to you I
just don't wanna get into a place where
I'm blocking his hunting we're making
too much noise I'd rather be closer
towards the road and have a long
distance view of him in the meantime
while he's kind of figures it out it's
the valuable learning experience for him
to try and start hunting things like
warthogs and so you know try and give
him as much leeway as possible and it's
actually quite interesting where he's
hunting right now I don't know if any of
you remember a few weeks ago we had this
insane elephant sighting on foot it's at
that exact term I'd madre we were
watching the elephants on foot the other
day so it's strange to think you're
sitting on that man and all these a
lipid running around all over the place
suppose that's true of where we walk
around here but it kind of just feels
bit different I don't know why it just
does and let's see it should be what's
that food it's like a turkey exactly I
should coming out somewhere in this
general vicinity I lost him around that
mount Fergus you see anything have you
got him oh there is yes he's going up
the mound itself so you can see him just
going up on top of the mound and I'm
pretty sure that's exactly where we sat
which is quite cool so that's where
David and I sought refuge from the 80s
you can see why it was a good spot
because the Ellie's when we were up
there could not see us much like we can
hardly see him I don't see any signs the
warthogs I'm gonna go forward a little
bit because there's a vehicle behind us
that probably won't be able to see him
too well and the warthogs don't seem to
be too close so I can just roll along on
the road and not have to stress too much
that we're going to give him away so
he's just on top there I think he's
going to come in our direction towards
where we are just kind of trying to keep
an eye on him because we know Sanne
hunts it's one of those things you've
got to be a bit careful of because he
tends to move around very very quickly
and he tends to kind of shake you quite
fast so it's important just to kind of
keep an eye on him as much as possible
when he is in hunting mode it's very
difficult to see him on top of that
mists of sticks and branches but a great
place for him to hide I mean watching
prey animals you can actually just see
him quite nicely there looks like he's
sickling down so I might actually go and
reposition ourselves given his settling
if he was not settled and was still
standing and watching and kind of tail
twitching I might have left it but we'll
wait for that vehicle to settle first
because they trying to get themselves
into position and it's funny I yesterday
I was two days ago when was it when we
had the wild dogs I was saying that a
friend of mine that was at Sangeeta with
me he was on a vehicle and there's
another one that is also from Sangeeta
that is busy guiding a group of guests
now that's in this particular vehicle so
lots of friends of mine that have come
through in the last few days which is
always quite nice but it's nice to catch
up with people that you haven't seen for
quite some time so nice to see them
around as well now yes there we go I was
going to ask you figure says I can't
hear anything but now I've got comes
again so I will send you across to David
in the Maasai Mara because my comms are
being funny and hopefully he'll have
some interesting things to show you that
are around
well good luck asana you might saw him
it have changed his mind and we got some
zebras here that was talking about
before and shortly before then I was
talking about illumination and how was
comparing that to human beings and what
crossed my mind is how ladies long time
would you know semi chew the food and
then feed their children and I was
thinking in my you know if it was me
those days how would I know when to chew
and when to stop and then say feed my
younger brother or my sister for example
if I was in my mother's shoes because
chances are if the food was too good out
and up swallowing everything in how
zebras are known ruminants unlike the
buffalos Oh many on top zebras do not
get you cut you just get them you know
grazing and eating as much grass as they
can and the tent always to survive very
well as much as they are known ruminants
and Steve good a feathered friend at the
moment yes we do we've got a very
beautiful bird one of the African hawk
eagles that our resident on Juma and
what's very interesting is have a look
at the big bulge on the front of the
chest
that is the crop as where a bird has
probably ingested or not ingest and
really but taken an enormous amount of
food through its mouth into the crop
where it actually stores it to bring it
back to the nest or for later use and we
are not far from the nest that there's a
breeding nest just up in one of the
trees I beheaded so maybe he's waiting
for I don't know what he's waiting for
to be honest I saw it with a fish eagle
the other day it gives the birds the
ability to bring food back to chicks on
the nest or to a partner that might be
waiting on the nest doing the most of
the incubation but often they seen in
pairs the hawk Eagles and they would
have a very high percentage of their
diet would be Franklin like we saw
before other things such as guinea fowl
as well very big into their game birds
but I can also take smaller mammals such
as squirrels small hairs even higher X's
I've even known to take Bush babies and
fruit bats which is quite interesting so
quite a varied diet and they're quite
well known for being sort of that that
they're - bird hunting sort of strategy
one will fly in and be a be sort of
observed and then they all move away and
then the second one comes in from the
side and smashes them from a very
stealthy position Sarah you want to know
whether we're air as bird as I have seen
well they're areas but we see here the
rarest bird we see here on Juma I would
say is probably the ground hornbills but
that's mainly because they're endangered
there's not too many of them around I
haven't yet seen a lappet-faced vulture
in the area cape vultures I've seen once
only once in this area I've seen leopard
face and coat vultures in the Kruger
Park
regarded as quite rare and endangered
and the ground hornbill but there's two
rivers in the kruger park they're all
defensive up sort of in the middle and
then the lava vu all up at the north and
on those two rivers there is special owl
species known as the Pels a fishing hour
which is the largest owl that we have
and as the name implies it is a fishing
owl and is often are competed by larger
large Raptors such as the fish eagle as
well as the giant eagle owl which we see
quite commonly I'll show you a picture
of the pearls fishing out if you like is
a nocturnal hunting specialist and they
like to hang around watching points and
here I've got a nice picture of it sorry
my screen but I think my fingers are
just grubby sorry Craig oh there we go
enormous big black eyes and it is a very
large bird 2.1 kilograms it doesn't give
away its its size there in this picture
but those black eyes are very
characteristic and that's it's on a log
that often sits on logs perched watching
the stream and they primarily feed on
fish they also feed on other things at
the time of the year but they are very
big fish eating bird but there's not
many of them left in South Africa we
need to conserve them anyway lots of
lots of hawk eagles around we're going
to leave this individual to see what it
is going to do now suppose it's going to
take its food back maybe its partner is
away foraging and it's waiting to see if
it would like some of the dinner its
procured who knows it's going to do but
anyway the crop is there it is full they
have eaten it has been a successful day
for this bird and in the meantime let us
go all the way back up - d'eryka - in
the Mara who has gotten some zebra oh
saying earlier you know as much as
zebras are known ruminants they tend to
survive better even when the weather
conditions are tough if for example is a
drought this little harder the IV's that
went a bit
yeah I guess that was the looking at
finding out what could be happening the
other direction they are looking at and
like that zebra Syria good looking zebra
if you look on the main they tend to
have a way yes
minimal how JEWS ever escaped themselves
in the African heat and they've always
being the big debate on ER the debate
straight on the zebras black and white
black absorbing more heat and white
tenant reflect hit away and we have
always wondered which stripes more is
that the black stripes or the Detroiters
to me
zebras tend to have more white than
black and of course whites tends to
deflect the heat away and they also have
a coat of hair you know on top of your
skin and that would also have not making
sure they don't absorb as much heat but
occasionally they'll also be seen or
sometimes say they're like on ecotone
areas that tend to go close to some
little Boucher's all your trees where
they would get some shade but I say the
white helps them all to keep themselves
cool if you look at this ones here
carefully you can see the black and
white and these being what you call the
Commons you brought the batch of zebra
you might think in the number of the
number of stripes are equal black or
white but in general I'll always tend to
think minimal they have more white than
black which is a big debate the stew
seems to be having a go on each other
I'm not sure for what reason and it's
all over ice time to feed and I was
saying even when you have big drought in
Africa or in certain areas like in the
Mara couple years ago
zebras which are known ruminants tend to
survive better they tend to adopt better
and will always tell a healthy or good
looking zebra if a chicken pan on one of
the mains on that on top of the hair on
top of the neck and when the main stays
upright like that leg of a horse you can
tell that the zebra is streamed
perfectly Wow well let's find out what
or sonics be up to in South Africa with
Tristan
well he stopped hunting his warthog and
has now decided that it's time to do
cuteness overload he had his head down
just now and as rubbing his head and
yawning and kind of looking at us and
just being a typical husana butt of a
clown really but he endeared himself
very quickly when he does those kind of
things it's difficult not to actually
just sit and watch him and kind of be a
little bit in awe of the fact that we
get to spend so much time with such a
well in the world terms elusive shy cat
that nobody else really gets to spend
that much time with and for to have kind
of been part of that process for the
last few weeks we have spent as much
time as we have with him has been
probably one of those very special
things that I don't know if we'll ever
truly understand how lucky we all are
and including everybody that's watching
because you know it's not every day that
you get to spend as much time focused if
you ever spent this much time with a
leopard before or like this no exactly
so fergus's was a-sayin Fergus has done
a lot of wildlife filming in his life
before we even safari live and to spend
so much time with the lipid is a very
very very special thing indeed and
especially one as charming and
charismatic is this particular fella
so janitor depends generally on average
here in the sabi sands we're looking at
two two Cubs quite common to have one in
the case of Tanisha's and the one that
we know about but quite common to see
one two sometimes three three is unusual
in the sabi sands in East Africa three
is is fairly common in fact even
reported cases of forth there but yeah I
don't think there's even ever a cooler
case of four lipid Cubs in the sabi
sands area or in the Kruger area as far
as I know might be wrong might have been
you know it's a lot of the times leopard
cubs don't get seen nents until one
might die and in in areas outside of the
sabi sands where there's not as many
track is and there's not as many roads
and places like the Kruger we've
discussed it many times that there's a
lot of areas there that are so big that
you won't actually see any sign of those
lipids lipids won't come across cause
they entire life and so those ones we
never know how many Cubs they really
have but the average for this particular
section is is two and it's a good case
study to have because we have such a
high density of leopard and we fringe
the Kruger that that should
theoretically carry and hold value going
into the Kruger itself as well so to
it's about an average like say sometimes
ones what you will find as well is that
young females and very old females they
tend to have smaller letters so one is
quite common for the first-time mother
and then as she goes a little bit older
she then starts to pay me have two three
through her her prime years and then as
she gets very old again
she'll start to go back down to kind of
having just the one so maybe that's what
happened with tandy you know she had two
all her life her first but second or
third we're all two and then she had
just the one in her fourth litter now so
be interesting to see if she's gonna
have a fertility I think she will I mean
I I hope she will she's feisty mom but a
very cool mom to have around and that
Colombo it's anything like that he's
such a such a cool little lipid and same
as tumba I mean tumblr was amazing and
even Baku tea and kochava no I'm sorry I
said that she had three that said four
wasn't she bullets is yes oh four five
five bits of sorry my math is not good
this morning I was just trying to
remember all of them
so as whether user in was booty in quit
Java nets for bullets is until Columbus
or lumber will make four and fifth one
might be interesting to see you I wonder
if she'll have a boy or a girl because
they were all boys before Colombo that
survived and in the total number came
along and it's the first little girl
that she's so far managing to get quite
old and this is obviously not out of
danger yet she's still got a long way to
go as we saw the shrinkie now we were
talking about something they're just not
thinking it was over a year old when
well over a year old when she had you
know this into interaction with tandy
and kind of disappeared and so little
Club a even though she's gotten out of
the really most dangerous phase of those
first three months she's still got a
long way to go until she's an adults
Lepidus that is successful and would be
interesting to see how she does and
where she goes and what she kind of gets
up to over the course of her life and
see whether she takes a bit of Tandy's
territory or what's going to happen you
know so much is unknown about what goes
on around us on our northern side and
our even our eastern side to a degree we
know that ton D goes into tortured but
we have no idea how far north in candy
and pushes what other female leopards up
there and therefore what are the
pressures little Colombo will face as
she goes through life it's going to be a
change in things now again I've got
comms issues once more so I believe that
our my linking to focus there was a
question okay hold on hold on repeat it
for me go again Megan let's try one more
time so Megan if you can yami but no
comms with Megan anymore witches say
Lindsey comes born at a certain time of
the yeah Thank You Fergus by the way um
do they have more of an advantage
probably not I mean it's why lipids will
give birth at random times of the year
they're quite happy to to do so anytime
at the end that's because generally and
if it can't find food you'll find though
that there is a period in the airway
it's it's somewhat easier and that's
normally the lambing season so this
spring into summer the early summer is a
good time for lipids mothers they can
catch small carcasses which means that
they can feed very quickly
back to the young and suckle as well as
if the young is a little bit older can
teach that one to young on small animal
only teach that one to hunt on smallish
animals
hello ho Sanna now everybody out there
needs to hope that husana stays exactly
where he is for this afternoon because
the Sun is going to sit directly behind
his head once again like whipped we had
the other day and so hopefully that will
be the case if he stays where he is I
doubt he's going to stay that long I
mean it's a long way away until the Sun
sets but let's grin can hope that's our
little principal or such as reading Lee
as years now for the remainder of the
afternoon isn't that beautiful I think
it's a very very spectacular now focus
you all have to try and help me with
things hopefully what we can do is maybe
somehow just figure it out this morning
we had the same issue with outcomes and
so I'm wondering if I just try and do
use a little patchwork system that we
did earlier and see maybe I can get it
right Megan can you talk to me just
while we live just so that I can
actually hear and see if I can hear you
no I'm not getting you MiG's right now
while I try and figure this out and try
and fix what's going on it sends you
back across to Steve who is just
bumbling about I am just driving at the
moment Oh what is that high in the sky
we had some vultures this morning that
it obviously followed up on an Akuma
kill let's see what looks like to me by
the way it flies and James Hendry has
laid down the gauntlet of who can see
the first Warburg's eagle and that is
definitely not a Warburg's eagle looks
to me to be a white back it's not the
easiest so there's two of them they're
going into a couple little thermal that
is generating above and they've probably
spent the day sitting down there and
that the gormers had some kill down on
our southern boundary we're not sure
what it was there were a few vultures
found there this morning and the
vultures have probably been sitting
there all day waiting for the heat it
hasn't been a warm day it's taken all
day for the clouds to clear and now are
slowly the heat is hitting the ground
and generating a thermal which is going
to hoist them high up into the sky and
then allow them to be able to move off
to wherever their roosting sites may be
some of the vultures are still nesting
or roosting at the moment coming towards
the end of the season for them
Celtx you want to know what parrots we
get you well very common parrot we get
you is is the brown headed parrot I
don't think you get the gray headed
around here great head it's quite a
special bird that you find up in
Zimbabwe and further north and right up
in the northern parts of Kruger you get
them there and also the mayor's parrot
occurs in it around that I don't think
the mayor's parrot has ever been here a
beautiful little birds they look just
like parrots as the name would imply so
you wouldn't mistake them for anything
else
very pretty birds we've actually got a
couple nesting close to the dam can
there's a little cavity in a tree there
that they're using I still haven't found
the tree I know that I've seen people on
the dam cam and showing it to us and
then every now and again I have a little
well I forget to really have a look
around the dam so much going on around
the dam these days that when you get
that you forget to look at the hole in
the tree there's a very camouflaged
animal we are still searching quite
deliberately for any signs of optin
ghana maybe even opt + E but as I was
saying after in the rain unless the
animals have moved in the mud the ground
gets quite hard it gets quite difficult
it'll take a couple days of driving on
these roads to soften them again and to
get that sort of that soft texture up
allow the tracks to be a little bit more
easy to see there's a beautiful new
honor we always paying attention to the
new allas and the kuru and the birds
because when it's hard to track well
these animals give us a very good idea
of where they are
you see his busy smelling and as ears
are moving around as the wind picks up
gets a bit jittery out there for these
animals this is it almost a mature adult
and so on a little bit of growth to be
done but it's probably quite a big guy
beautiful and he likely an Impala will
be benefiting soon with the little flash
that comes up from the vegetation from
the grass and any of the leaves but
we've had that little bit of rainfall
what the ground needs is a day or two of
sunshine to to bake it and to react and
to cause the photosynthesis to start
happening and the leaves to start
pushing themselves out then your lap
being a mixed feeder
there's far better this time of year
then their cousin the kudu
who are exclusively browsers and I'm
sure over the next few weeks we're gonna
be seeing some very skinny kudu king sy
they are very pretty we've all had the
debates about which maybe we should do
it again let's do it to to poll this
afternoon shall we what is the most
pretty antelope the kuru bull or the
Nala ball sent through your tweets to
tap not yalla or kuru one-word answer
okay well we just quickly get a little
look in the grass there
but we're going to be running away to
the Masai Mara leaving our steel market
in the grass let's go to David and a
gazelle
well formas ten we got at Thomson
gazelle this is what should call our
steam box in East Africa and earlier I
was talking of one of the first fastest
small antelopes
in Africa which was the Thomson gazelle
and now we got what hog bear you got a
peak there in the foreground if you look
carefully that grayish and move that
seems to be kneeling down crazy
it is a pig what tug and you've seen the
difference between what rogue and the
tummy this was well he is not flicking
the tail but you can look at the tummy
there the tail is constant on the move
well done RG see that always in the move
but peak is not much as much of course
the different species of animals but
that's one with the difference for more
chickens in the screen there the tummies
keep moving and the Warthog is moving on
the right not flicking the tail at all
maybe not to dinner very popular with
the Flies like the Thomson gazelles and
in the matter where we are
so if there's a vehicle way in the
background there this is the favourite
food for the Cheetahs and that's the boy
and both boys and girls will have the
horns I don't know why that he is like
running there and from the background
there I can hear some bad no key or a
tree and I would guess that should be I
would pick up that's way in the
background
time for bit of a scratch
hello they're very fast model guys they
look tiny but they're very soothed and
Megan is enjoying our Springboks from
East Africa King Phi is true and
comments you like how they wag their
tails and it's constant you know I do
not know how much killer killer killer I
know just kilocalories they use to keep
in avoiding those tears I did it for
morning to afternoon or to the evening
but look through the magic and the
Christmas is always lip flux or is it
only flies in the background they look
carefully there's a different species of
antelope cane fire still obvious still
watching and that is an Impala
it's huge male and Steve oval alia was
talking about the impalas in East Africa
having much bigger haunts than the ones
in South Africa and I would agree with
you Steve and he doesn't he's not moving
or wagging his tail like the tummy's
well having seen that he does exactly
that but you can see the pace in the
frequency is much different than the
Tommy's I think the tummies are smaller
maybe the skin is much softer and maybe
they are more prone to the flies than
the Impala because you look at the tummy
and look at the pace of them one in
their tails compared to the slowest
sluggish wagging of the impala keep
moving it keep moving it a similar
species to this but slightly bit bigger
would be the grant's gazelle and you'd
be definitely together the tummy's and
the impala because of safety in numbers
and the more you they are together is
good for them they're able to be able to
spot any predator from reasons and let's
find out Steve over what you are - in
South Africa
I move on looking for McGann yes well
we've found a beautiful track of a
lioness and this is no doubt from the -
one of the two that we were with last
night it's come exactly from the area we
were in and you can see that the track
is a little bit messy and you can tell
that it happened while it was still
raining can see that by the fact that
the soil particles inside or a little
bit moist that's a bit spongy from their
witness but it hasn't really dried too
much in the sunshine today but what I
wanted to show you is that now because
things are drying outside that if Craig
just tracks up from that you'll see that
because that's just a little sandy patch
there that's where the track is
beautiful but look at the conditions we
have the rest of the roads are hard and
tough like that no are the tracks
invisible so just when you get a little
bit of a depression and a nice soft sort
of sandy but will you get some tracks so
that's what happens is this time of year
after we've had some rain the tracks
become very difficult to see every now
and again you get just one to stack them
that looks like that small lioness from
last night that ended up joining the
risk that when coomer's with Justin this
morning and her and her her mum I
believe I thought I was I was correct in
saying that the adult female last night
was the youngest one but Justin
corrected me instead as the ribs nurse
female and that was in fact her daughter
and they moved off and hunted last night
after we left them we could tell by the
fact that they had an enormous belly and
by the way they were moving seemed like
they used the wind sorry mags you said
the quiz who is the ultimate winner of
the quiz this afternoon
okay so the niala has been given the
prize for the most pretty of the
antelope between kuru and Yael and I
must agree I love could you I do love
kudu but I just like the size of the
kudu but the niala the way he dances the
way they perform those beautiful long
orange socks the whites on the face
they're very pretty animal very very
pretty so I will agree they are the
prettier of the two and the kudu are the
bigger of the two
you can't win both of them can you can't
be the biggest and the prettiest
sometimes the pretty has to be smaller
but in the meantime we're still going to
be checking these areas for any signs of
a cat or two I mean Sam let's go today
but who's got himself a bird of prey I
know Steve over is very good in trucking
but now I'll first give you a small quiz
and you tell me which the big bad is
them there's a big R after their big
bird of prey but if you look to the
right this is smaller bad and you got a
very interesting scenario here the bird
on the right is code for children gone
and bats of this size
I personally respect the drongos they're
very small but they're very very
courageous so it's alone now but if any
other drone go will come and join this
one here you'll see them trying to moba
the big bird of prey which as again as I
said I want you look at that Raptor
carefully and you tell me who do you
think that is - Royce the four children
go and initially there were two and what
they're trying to do is to intimidate
this big bird of prey here to go away
you see what they're doing
okay see that okay they keep trying to
fly over it trying to poke its eyes they
just try to irritate look at that now
they're three
he or she isn't moving she isn't being
intimidated but I can tell you drongos
are very small buds but I've known them
to have lots of courage and they're
never scared by the size of a you know
over rough like this one here
remember I've pushed that question to
all of you news viewers hashtag Safari
live and please send through your
answers Nikita you think's a brown snake
he got keep trying
I'll get use the answer look at the
shape of the head and more snake he goes
we'll have rounded heads but that's good
cast Nikita you said brown snake eagle
as you should keep sending your answers
hashtag Safari live but for the fact we
got the two they on the right to each
our [ __ ] children goes and they're
making sure this rafter will go so
they'll stay there for couple of seconds
and then go for it and I can tell you
they're not going to let go until she
leaves that area they've been known to
go for the drongos the big rafters
Ashley
you think about Leah you think about
Leah maybe not Ashley maybe not but
that's sort of very bad gas ask me
it could be not quite so we had a bath
here before we had a brown snake hero
before maybe not those two keep trying
and I'm sure you have seen it keep going
through your IDs and I'm sure we might
get the answer as I'm getting some news
that could be something interestingly
I'll give you one more look on that
Raptor there and then I'm sure we'll be
getting the answer to know who that is
the bad clear maybe not quite how creepy
this bow shaky go you go to Paul there
keep trying look at the [ __ ] told wrong
go there I'll also get my file Luke has
to have one more quick click on it
Josh Hill bull bots eagle and I think
you're right
Wahlberg's Eagle I think that could be
it because initially I chose a Tony I
think this could be the wallbox ego joy
and I would say well done and hopefully
I give you credit for what's right it's
more bugs
Eagle than any other you go to think of
all right thank you very much John and
let's find out what Tristan will tell us
about husana now
well very nice David nice to hear the
Wahlberg's are around it means that they
coming south which is always good news
so hopefully they'll be back on our side
fairly shortly they should be nearly at
the end of August meaning of September
is about the right time for them as well
as the booted Eagles they should be
arriving or to arrived already so it'll
be a good time right
but Sanne has been lying facing us the
whole time posing with his foot on a
stump and his now decided to turn around
so I'm just gonna go around quickly so
he can see him better because with the
lights behind him and he's so on the
mound and the Sun is slowly going
downwards but I really don't think he's
going to be up there for all that much
longer starting to look as though he's
getting little on the twitchy side of
life where he wants to start thinking
about moving but this light on him at
the moment is spectacular
which I will show you shortly look at
this is that not absolutely beautiful
and a boy are you posing for us as
nicely as one could ever ask for it
seems like it it seems like he's got
this posing thing down pat wherever
whatever school he went to for posing
he's definitely doing a good job of it
he's really kind of gets it right he
gets on - these are beautiful mounds
from time to time and really does look
fantastic when he's up on them Catherine
he is so relaxed we're so fortunate that
we have a leopard like this so in this
like I say many many guides it spend a
lot of their time working in a lot of
different game reserves that we'll never
get to spend time with a leopard the way
we get to spend with husana and so we
are more than fortunate with what goes
on with this cat and and the fact that
we get to see him the way that we do it
really is a very very very special thing
that we get to follow him as much as
what we do right now I believe that a
flare image looks very cool as he sits
on top of the mound as he Grace's us
with his kind of beauty and you can see
how hot he is as well as how hot the
termite mound is it's pretty cool to
actually see it the way that he's
sitting up there and you can see that
they are parts the termite mound the
exterior parts it a little bit cold but
otherwise his rosettes very very hot and
the termite mound very hot the rest of
the butcher
I'm cold so it gives you an idea of just
how hot the termite mound is it's kind
of registering the same heat as him in
the Sun which gives you a good
indication of how warm they are during
in relation to the rest of the bush
around them I mean there's not too much
vegetation around him but what
vegetation there is you can hardly see
when he is sitting like that but sauna
butterfly boy is fainting yarn which is
an indication that maybe just maybe
husana is going to start thinking about
moving which would not surprise me at
all given that he's been sitting on this
man for 10 minutes or 20 minutes should
I say he is not the most chilled cat
when it comes to afternoon activities
and so he's were places to be things to
see things to hunt go to look at and I
wouldn't be surprised if that's why he's
contemplating going on a bit of a
walkabout now oh is that not
ridiculously beautiful no sauna
are you adorning all your fans boy looks
like it just kind of peering over his
shoulder at the moment it's listening to
some Franklin's that are alarm calling
behind us I don't think they alarm
calling at him
so the reason the rosettes were warmer
Jennifer's because they're black and so
the black rosettes are heating up
quicker than the white and gold fur that
he's got on him or yellowish fur and so
therefore he's got darkest or mean
hotter spots showing around that black
area it's and it's much like if you have
a black jersey on as opposed to a white
jersey and you go stand in the Sun
you're gonna feel much hotter much
quicker in the black coloration and
absorbs light a lot more then what
absorbs heat should I say a lot more and
so that's why to a nighttime period and
the sun goes down there isit's go
completely the same as as the coach very
quickly actually as the Sun sets it
doesn't take long at all so it's only
just because the Sun is hitting that
area and it's being more light as there
well more heat is being absorbed by the
black coloration in the rest but it's
that's the only reason is that it's a
darker color in contrast to the rest of
the body that is the whites and gold
tones which reflects light a lot more
than what's black does so that's why
you'll see a lot of interesting things
with things like frogs and particularly
a phoneless tree frog it's actually will
go from a Turkish gray color and it will
change to white during the course of the
day to try and reflect lights and to
make it lose less moisture but it's very
cool to see amazing isn't it this FLIR
is the most amazing camera it really has
saved our bacon in many respects so I
know it sounds funny but over the course
of the past few weeks we've been art
it's 3 o'clock in the morning 4 o'clock
in the morning 5 o'clock it's dark and
then into the night to the artists flair
we would have lost half the amount of
animals that you've seen and we wouldn't
have gained some intimate kind of
knowledge into a lot of things that have
gone on so you know we've seen black bee
in Kakuma female with a little wound on
it on a hip now it's either showing much
hotter because of a of an infection or
because it's lacking insulation of the
fur itself and so that's why you seeing
that hot spot cunning glowing the way it
is but it's interesting to see you
alright hasana me the time to walk now
are we going to the pan to go and
indulge everybody hmm I think so right
that's my head let's get that out the
way now Meghan I hope that while we
drive we're going to keep calm just
because it's my little earpiece thingy
where it plugs in that's a bit dodgy and
so if it Wiggles too much then I'll lose
comms but it will be interesting to see
if how we drive if
stays okay I've tried to tape it and
make a good kind of thing but anyway
while we carry on with our cats
it sounds like David in the Maasai Mara
well he's found his cats for the
afternoon in the Mara triangle and got a
couple of lions here you can see that
one panting they are through the grass
and this frayed is what we call the
marsh pride this is a mush spread where
we are I've counted about five of the
marsh pride and I think depending on the
age or the size of the right you can see
that panting comparing to the one we saw
before I'd switch the one we saw earlier
you see the difference in panting one
it's much faster than the other
could it be difference in age difference
in size having different amount of food
in the tummy one is like up down down
see like that one there and then achieve
you go to the left which is that one
little much faster panting then the
other one and again sorry mates you some
no it's the background of another car
just moving come in to enjoy this is
much so it's like this kind of Britons
between or panties between the two
they're like I've got a scar there I
think I saw scar on that back right leg
and things will happen sometimes when
they Chloe each other who gets females
you know fighting amongst among us
themselves to the happens once in the
oil and or it could be tipping
event great lanes are so cool and when
you see them in such an area hidden
across having eaten and they just laying
there and blending in so an event I
would say yes who would not want to see
miles in such a place and have always
said any day I see lions is a beautiful
day it's a great day just laying down
here of course because of the heat of
the day and as it cools off they might
be moving this Marsh pride is always
very big over 10 of them here after
counted about five and we tend to think
maybe another five would be not very far
from here and if we're lucky we might
see the coalition of the boys or the
males it's always coming around to met
with these females here if you go back
to the Lions Archie that you call the
triangle boys sorry about to my head
they're my friends for me about to this
much fried laying down here otherwise
it's very easy just to drive and miss
them when they especially they flood
down in the grass there the wind is
picking up you can see the grass being
blown by the wind there should be
another car just passing not very far
for me I was enjoying the beauty of the
Lions and again as I said this was a
tail flicking up of the mass pride
sometimes as gage you get frustrated
when you look for a blue lions and you
miss them but sometimes if you see tail
flick up like that you know there could
be something Steve let us know I'm good
try and reposition so they could see
them better in a different way about
Steve something for us yes we do we have
found a beautiful bird down in the
Milwaukee drainage system I wonder how
many of the viewers out there have got
their bird books with him today on a
willing to try and identify this bird
for me here's a very pretty bird
you can see him there the red beak the
whitish sort of chest
really only confused with two and the
light is not great Craig actually I
think you're right Craig a the light is
not great but oh did you hear him
calling what is him calling they're off
you guys they stopped in the tree very
good there is Rove ended is definitely a
Kingfisher there we go he's given us a
much nicer view of himself
Ravenna definite Amalekite definite am
Ellicott Kingfisher melakartas
completely blue Brad sushant uric and a
brown hoodie Kingfisher that was my
original thought and I'm still thinking
it is but by the fact that there's but
more sort of brown on the lower belly
I'm actually gonna go with them almost a
gray headed he's got a brown on the
belly it's not the most you should have
but more streaking on the chest if it
was a brown who the Kingfisher but the
lights you see the lights are showing
he's got that collar there on his neck
which is obviously normally something
you see with the brown hooded but it's
very interesting because I've got a few
pictures here that show a bra
gray-headed looking very similar so very
hard to actually ascertain right now we
need to get a another view of him but we
could hear him calling before so let's
see if we can play this call in some our
microphone deftly didn't sound like a
brown hooded Kingfisher call that was
him calling me well that was me calling
on my phone
mmm James no not yet we wouldn't get
Woodlands here yet and woodlands are
very very different in their color you
wouldn't be able to confuse a woodland
with these two with the grey headed and
the brown hundred I have seen a grey
headed before in the drainage chair and
Craig has actually he thought as we
landed here it was a grey headed Oh
and he's gone but let me show you the
two pictures here one the - greasy
fingers for some reason here's the
beautiful picture of the two and you can
see the gray headed on the left the
beaks are very similar and you see the
collar I was talking about on the brown
hood but the gray headed has also got it
over there and when he flew over he
definitely had a very blue blue blue
blue purplish blue on the back versus a
light turquoise blue over here and the
beak looked to be uniformly red rather
than a little bit of a tip on the red so
normally I've noticed them because the
the belly on the gray headed has got a
very half sort of scented belly
very very Brown and the belly but look
if I change this picture look at that
suddenly he's got a very low brown belly
so and look at that so very very similar
indeed but I'm I'm gonna go with you
Craig go on your initial idea and say
gray headed Kingfisher any of you out
there disagree with me you're welcome to
just send through your comments but
definitely quite a special bird we don't
get to see too many of them I've seen
this program a third time here in Juma
seeing one but before that only seen at
a handful of times in my life whereas
the brown hooded czar very very common
okay well we're gonna keep going down
the hall more watch it and see where we
get to in the meantime let's go and see
what the little chief is up to well the
little chief is in the most beautiful
golden light that you can imagine he's
just sitting watching slowly strolling
through the long winter eat grass and
there's this back light that's coming
down and it isn't that just the most
spectacular seen of him he really has
spoilt us with beauty
any kind of thing about him is that he's
active at these times of the day when
the light is so good and that's why they
often get these amazing kind of screen
shots I've seen lots of you been posting
lots of screenshots about him and
there's been some amazing views of this
little cat between all of us we've all
been very very fortunate now what are
you doing what sauna are you going to
come our way please come our way looks
like he's going to he's got his little
tail up it's because he's being shouted
at by a hotel trongo
oh that is beautiful Petru you never
know
it's obviously a very difficult thing to
do 100% say yes or no yes they will be I
suppose there will be a bit of a change
in his personality in his behavior as he
becomes more dominant he's obviously
gonna have to do a lot more work in to
be able to he's gonna come this way
let's just reverse back so we don't
block his path so he can go where he
wants to go sorry wait I didn't know
which way you wanted to go more okay so
you know he's gonna have to become a
dominant male which means that he's
gonna have to you know at some point
defend his territory which means he
can't be as nice to other leopards as he
is he's also you know mating is going to
change that whole thing testosterone so
his behavior will change slightly and he
won't be quite the same leopard that we
know today which is a little bit of a
shame in some respects I hope that he's
still quite an active cat and moves
around and hands a lot and does his
thing and catches a lot of different
prey items I hope that that's the case
but you never know with him it's gonna
be an interesting kind of look at his
behavior as he develops and becomes a
dominant individual hopefully we do get
to look at it and we get to watch it
from where we are here and that it
doesn't happen away from us where we
can't see him and can't follow him now
husana do you really have to go today
yes I do have to go there okay
well it's going to be a very difficult
time to follow him through where he's
heading that is not an easy place that
he is going at all so we're gonna try
and kind of figure it out a lot of you
might remember a sighting of tumba under
that very very tree we had an epic
sighting of tumba the one day sitting
right there now I'm gonna try and catch
up with him because once he goes in here
if I don't stay with him we going to
lose him very creepy so while I do that
and try and keep up with the little
chief as he takes us on a walkabout for
the afternoon let's send you a back
across to David who is just bumbling
about what a beautiful wall they got now
the temperatures have gone down and we
have magnificent lights and I'm trying
to imagine every cut of scene today well
normally cars just lawyers will be time
for them now to rise and shine and I
also got some wind also someone might
have spotted the triangle boys I was
talking about the mash bride alia and in
this particular area we are the mara
triangle it has different price of lions
the marsh pride is one of them there's
another price for the breakaway Marsh
pride we got all our low Marsh pride
there's another pride code the maguro
pride and what I'm thinking or I'm
saying this particular form is that you
call the triangle boys that you always
met with these different sets of pres of
lions so if we are lucky we might be
driving in the direction and you might
be able to see the coalition of the try
and avoid this
people and Monique of the MIR cuffs
would be the mongooses sounds good
so Mia cuts maybe in South Africa Megan
the final control you might correct me
but in East Africa and more so in Kenya
I don't think we have any mere cuts and
any close species to that would be their
Mongoose we got the band-aid on stretch
Mongoose we got the draft Mongoose those
are what we'd call our makers we have
seen them once in a while the mongooses
I'm talking about standing on their hind
legs and looking like this sometimes
like screws so just Monique I do not
think we have enemy occurs in East
Africa
I had seen a rainbow alley I don't know
why the rainbow has gone
let me turn around
I don't know how bright it looks but I
thought arches were a rainbow now it's
gone yeah it's gone
yeah you see those beautiful bars flying
up in the sky how high are they they
look like a dress to me but I know you
have your magic Archie very good this
egrets flying over there and I got a
feeling they are heading all the way to
South Africa and they might request
Steve to tell us something small or big
about the meerkats yes hello everybody
well I do have an answer for the
meerkats here is first of all a picture
of the meerkats and they're very sort of
upright standing posts only did that the
other day and here there's their
beautiful shape and here is how they're
distributed across South Africa they're
very much sort of to the west so the
Namibian side down the west coast and
sort of in the middle of the country and
they come all the way down to the
Eastern Cape but they don't overlap with
the low felt the low felt hood
transition all the way around on the
other side there so no meerkats
where we are and if I show you a picture
of where the banded mongoose or the
whites are mongoose for example here
here the banner mongoose there we go you
can see the overlap over here the whole
of the low felt into Mozambique they
sort of fooled that sort of niche of
where the meerkats would fall in the
West so kind of very similar sort of
species and they out compete each other
by just avoiding so one is here the
other one is there so they're don't
coexist that's obviously over very long
time
and that answers your questions about
the meerkats but do you believe that
wild earth was involved in me a cat
stuff for a while and Craig there were a
meerkat filming stuff I don't know the
history but I think they did Graham had
although there's a picture of Peter one
of our technical directors walking
around with one of these very
interesting cameras performing the
meerkats on the ground I'm not mistaken
hmm I do I don't know if it was me a cat
manner who produced me a cat Nana could
have been Graham I'm sure someone out
there knows okay
hello zebras
don't run guys they're a little bit
skittish because we're on our fire break
right now a southern fire break and this
morning when seminar set up the drone
for our night tracking and our search
and ID with a thermal-imaging camera
we heard lions roaring from the south
and we were very excited to try and find
out who there weren't so we came flying
all the way down so pretty much where we
are now and that we found the whole
Oklahoma pride moving in the same
direction we're moving at the moment so
their tracks are all over the road here
their bellies were quite full maybe they
ate something the size of a zebra or a
water buckets hard to say but what we do
know is that the male lions were calling
on the eastern side on the Torchwood
ochita cutline boundary and every time
they called these Lions would run don't
move even quicker so obviously and
that's what made me think it was the
Avoca sand not the Birmingham boys and
Tristan went into the area and indeed
found at least one of our male and that
yeah
the warmers aren't too interested in
hanging out with the Evoque has just yet
when I first need to prove themselves
and they are not of the fathers of any
of the kids or the youngsters in the
Pratt so there's a bit of risk involved
and so no doubt these zebras can smell
where the Lions work and James with
Craig came here in the morning in front
of them all the way to the west where
they're crossed out obviously they're
before later they came back and Tristan
got that wonderful morning of all of
them coming back and rejoining each
other and the pride is now once again
complete the oxpecker in tow the zebra
feeding quite low to the ground they
have the ability to crop the grass
because they've got teeth on the top and
the bottom of the the front jaw which
enables them to actually chew the grass
down and they facilitate better feeding
for a lot of the other animals that
would be really annoying wouldn't it
having a bird clinging to your face okay
well it looks like we're going to get
quickly over to Tristan
little chief well the little prince is
now hunting something he's been focused
he's been using the sandbank to walk you
can see the tails twitching and we had
him just now leopard crawling all the
way along the sand and it was amazing
kind of to watch his patience and his
stealth now I think he spotted something
like a duiker maybe in front of us
there's a jackal burying up in front
that's ahead of him a big tall jackal
berry that has fruits that often drop
onto the floor and that means that you
you know find a number of different
antelopes that will come and eat certain
Yala's duikers those kind of things that
will move in that direction and they
will then feed off those and this is a
great place for a lipid to be able to
hunt I can't see anything yet and so I'm
wondering if maybe just maybe there
isn't some sort of sign now I can also
hear on the radio that tingle has been
found at philemon steps so if Steve is
around Megan maybe just pass on the
message I don't hear him on the radio so
I'm not sure if he's got his radio on
but tin gana is at Philemon step if
Steve does want to go into that
direction which I'm sure he does I know
he has been looking for ting gana most
of the afternoon right now
I wonder what's going on here I just
want to try and just sneak forward a
little bit just to see rhombus Bend what
he's watching but it was amazing to kind
of see him he was down on his tummy and
he was just crawling look look you see
how he uses the noise of the car which
is noisy a little bit but he's learning
and a lot of the lipids archaea are have
learned this behavior let's just see
where he's gonna go now it looks like
he's going to keep going straight what's
that there there's something there
that's close to the jackal Barry the
base of the jackal Barry I see something
that's a Franklin okay that's not what
he's looking at he's looking at
something here though for sure
he's just trotted off to my left hand
side so there he is there
now what what have you seen boy he's
definitely stalking something now let's
just see how long it's gonna take him to
get closer so worried that we might lose
him here here he goes
he's walking quite quickly Nan's not
really that covered so I don't know what
he's spotted maybe it bolted off before
he got there well he's just in one of
those moods but he's different if he was
stalking something there was an intent
to his walk and the way that he was
going about things and that telltale
sort of tailed dangle that he does will
wiggle is normally quite good sign that
something's going on but let's just keep
pushing for this some Elly is somewhere
close by too because I can hear them and
there's lots of evidence of them digging
around here in the Malati
so I wonder where they are maybe that's
what he's watching so I know what do you
see he's just on our left-hand side
so he's just watching I'm trying to stay
there he goes look at that he's not
rotting forward I don't see anything
running in front of him so we're gonna
try and keep up with him
he's really cared me quite tricky when
he's hunting like this because he covers
ground much faster than what we can and
he moves through these thickets much
faster than we can the good thing is is
that we've we stay down here in the
drainage line I'm quite happy because
most the animals are used to us driving
on this road they don't care too much
for us moving in this direction they
actually quite used to us while driving
here and so we're not going to spook too
much if we do nice on my left hand side
back lift his way is I still don't see
any sign of a prey animal their eyesight
is just unbelievable look at that isn't
that amazing I level with the stalking
leopard is quite spectacular there he
goes now Megan I'm not sure what she's
hunting but maybe let's take this to all
the other platforms that we're on so
more people can watch the amazing lipid
stalk that is taking place at the moment
oh there it is there's what's he's
hunting it's a dyke in front so we can a
quickly go live so I'm gonna hold of
speaking for a little bit
well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to this live broadcast from
Africa at the moment what you looking at
he's a whole bunch of grass and leaves
but hidden inside there he's a male
leopard that is busy hunting what he's
doing is he stalking along very slowly
there's a prey animal straight in front
of us that he's busy trying to get
closer to and it takes all of his guile
and his agility to try and sneak through
these thickets and try and then ambush
this animal the animal like I say it's
just sitting right in the middle of a
riverbed a dry riverbed and it is the
perfect place for a leopard to be able
to try and stalk forward now I don't see
him there I wonder if he's still kind of
coming forward he was creeping slowly
the Dyke here in front hasn't really
seen anything now it's just run off sir
I wonder if he's going to move a little
bit we're gonna try and just catch up
with that in case he's run off now my
name is Justin and on camera I've got
Ferg and we are coming to you live which
means that you can interact with us and
you can do so by going to posting
questions or comments in the comment
section below there he is look he's just
stalking so he's nice and low to the
ground look you see him there so he's
various now look at that camouflage
isn't that amazing
he's just sneaking through the thickets
and staying as low as possible so as not
to give himself away it's very cool to
the witness when you watch lipids move
like this I'm gonna try and just get a
little bit further forward you can see
the Sun is slowly setting as well which
is a good time areas he straighten that
gap which is nice so there he is going
to try and get low low low look at his
head that's down now this is a very kind
of good you want unique view of a lipid
hunting because generally you look down
on them a little bit but we are i level
with him as he's going and watch how
he's gonna place his paws slowly and
delicately making sure that he's not
making too much noise and he's watching
trying to calculate where's the steiker
going to move is it going to go left
it's going again to go right and try and
get himself into a place where he can
ambush it now
leopard is not fast like a cheetah that
can run incredibly quickly it needs to
position itself that the tiger comes
very very close and it can then grab it
from there so they try and get into a
pathway of that dike and then they sit
and wait and as it comes closer they'll
then try and use that incredible turn of
speed and burst out and catch the animal
unaware so he is a very good dykey
hunter
he's been hunting a lot of late and so
he's looking around I wonder if that Dai
kid didn't found off a little bit
further then he initially thought
because he's popped up quite high now
and generally when a leopard is very
close it stays as long as possible so as
not to be seen
Gisele you say wow how beautiful well
they are one of the most beautiful
animals in fact my favorite animal that
we have Archer
their coats are incredibly pretty and so
it is a beautiful scene to kind of watch
the slippered ghosting through these
thickets Sun is sitting in the
background it's the perfect time of day
for a little bit to be on the hand look
at that and you see how well his
camouflage works that broken patterned
outline just makes him blend in very
well now Alverno our losses not
disturbing him this particular leopard
has grown up around cars and around
people talking and so he doesn't really
focus on us at all what we need to do is
just try and keep our voices down so
that we don't disturb his hand too much
and that's why we kind of stay back a
little bit and allow him to walk his in
the direction that he wants to go and
also not try get too close to his prey
animal my the last time I saw the prey
animal that he was hunting was just kind
of coming from this section here and we
would just bounded up onto the top so it
went in the direction of where he is I
just want to go a little bit further it
goes there it goes it just ran across
now hopefully I think he must
unfortunately now you know his success
rate well the success rate of lipids is
better than sometimes lion and cheetah
but still not great so they only could
kill about 30% of the animals that they
actually hunt but that Dyke I think saw
him and ran because it just burst
through here now I don't know where he's
gone he might have chased it
I've lost him now but he should be
somewhere here he normally wear the
leopard when they miss they stop
straightaway and they watch where that
duiker maybe went I think let's just go
back again a little bit there's a little
gully here that he might have been in
and that's where he could have maybe
missed I didn't see him cross on to the
side now he would have if he was right
behind the dike or wood across the this
riverbed which he hasn't so I think he
must still be sitting somewhere close by
and maybe he just there is so he's
popped his head up now a little bit more
Fergus is telling me he's just watching
where that dye Koran I don't think he's
got much of a chance now the dike is
sensed that there is a leopard around
and is very wary it's been bolting and
so I think it saw him and has now run
off unfortunately they are very very
aware animals and they often do pick up
live as long before he'll if it actually
can get too close anyway it was an
amazing thing to watch hopefully you all
enjoyed it if he does continue to hunt
or shall we go live once again but
hopefully we'll see you all another time
sometime soon
right well unfortunately he missed I'm
sure he's gonna keep hunting and
hopefully you'll get a meal in the
meantime that sends you across to Steve
he sounds like he's caught up with ting
gana
yes well here he is the Duke of Juma
himself moving in a northerly direction
just like his son there must be some
nice wind that he is following how we're
going to follow him now okay
let's go back
Oh spit out
[Music]
spotted eagle owl just started them out
of the bush yeah how beautiful is that
okay well we gonna have to keep up with
the Juke there so sorry that I'm moving
off he has gone into very interesting
drainage you're gonna have to try and
find an access I don't know if you've
seen an access here before Craig oh
maybe he'll come up maybe he'll cross if
we can find an area to cross then we
will take it there he is over there okay
I think it narrows a little bit this is
a sorry about the bumps Craig oh this is
a bit of a drainage depression that
sandy really enjoyed frequenting with
little fur Lambo we've spent a lot of
time with her just down there but some
amazing shots
I think we might have some access just
here there he is right in front of us
it's probably going to follow this
drainage line for a little while so it's
tricky to know if we should cross or not
he's looking for Dacres and small
antelope that might secret themselves
inside a little drainage depression like
this this is always where the tricky
part comes do you follow him in or do
you wait on the other side okay well
while we try and find an access here
he's going over there try and get his
the general direction there's big male
the dominant male leopard of Zuma looks
like david has found himself a big male
lion well I was earlier talking about
the triangle boys and this boy's tough
boys whoops
am I talking about they got five six
different sets of prezerv lions they met
with this particular one that you see
here look at its tail carefully [ __ ] if
you could be a good boy I know you'll is
very kind and good boy if you notice the
tail is cut and this particular one is
called the short tail the total number
of the triangle boys are four what we
have now here we've got to this one the
short tail turning around and I think
either to the left actually very good
and this is called Fung I do not know
where the other two are but they're
always four is always a collision of
form strong males and they have been in
charged and ruling this territory for a
long time they have dealt with any other
coalition of males in like minutes you
can tell the strong men lots of flies on
them all those black spots acedia thighs
very good touchy and as you can see the
wind picking up but the wind is not
strong enough to blow the flies away but
you can see the Mohawk and the main
being blown by the wind together with
the grass
not punting as much like the females we
saw earlier as much as the males tend to
be bigger and stocky and heavier than
the femurs but this is quite a cool you
know panting as much as the temperatures
have tremendously dropped very typical
location for them to see their you know
the lioness and a tree and Megan in the
final controls he is awesome because
alia Orand was hot they definitely
needed the shade of that tree that's
called a Bosque a tree and they're not
very far from the females Nikita how are
you and you'd want to win this calf is
he still around yes the last I had off
Scarface was about let me see about a
week ago in Qatar I heard about Scarface
and apparently he was meeting and here
two females with him and since then for
the last one week I haven't seen him
haven't been able or had any news about
him but Scarface is around and I'm sure
Nikita you know Scarface big boy huge
men sometimes we have called him you
know Bob Marley because of his huge
mohawk that comes out like that
that he falls on his shoulders yes
Nikita Scarface is still around and I
think you know live and kicking and it
would compass compass to the main of
these if you look so there's a
helicopter they are passing of us and I
think those are just a game Rangers
dream then our Patrol and we'll move
from these two cuts here and go to a
spotted cut all the way in South Africa
well these are not spotted cats of
course these are impalas which are often
eaten by spotted cats here they are
having a drink at the juma pan and that
is because it has been a very warm and
pleasant afternoon and Impala especially
in the dry season are highly water
dependent creatures
this is the first time you've heard from
me today my name is James and I'm
sitting not actually in the water hole
I'm sitting in a tent not too far from
the water hole and I'm enjoying the
scenes that our nest cameras are
producing here yes Paula the pretty sky
indeed it is a magnificent afternoon
just the right temperature the cold
front left us earlier today and was
replaced by clear skies and lovely
spring ish temperatures should we say in
parlor you can see are deeply
appreciative of the fact that the foul
Ness of the last few days have
disappeared from the sky
well yes giraffes will dinner for horse
honor indeed he has tried possibly this
very herd of Impala at this very pan any
number of times but he hasn't managed to
get one here just yet and I'm not sure
that he will they're very wily and
there's just seems to be not quite
enough cover leading up to the pan so I
think they're probably easier Impala
meals to be had elsewhere on the reserve
other than at this water but dicus
certainly he's had success with here
he's eaten a Terrapin to try imagine was
fairly smelly you can see the Sun just
sunk there on this perfect Sunday
afternoon in mid-august you couldn't
believe it it's pall of the reflections
in the water are delightful as are the
ripples is something about water that
makes us human beings feel at peace feel
comforted I know that when people go to
the bush they almost always have their
sundowners or drinks near water or their
picnics and that's obviously in the hope
that they can watch some animals but at
the same time it just gives them sort of
a a peaceful feeling I think I'm not
really sure why that should be the case
possibly because we need to drink it I
wouldn't suggest you have any drink out
of this particular pan because I think
you'll get quite sick quite quickly now
we've got mail lipids good low all over
the
place let's go back to the older one now
while the Juke himself after a
spattering of rain is walking his domain
scent-marking
he might call soon if he gets spotted by
any prey animal he might call as you've
seen him do before but after territorial
spraying in his form of moisture will
wash away his scent so he will need to
resend mark and re sort of indicate that
he is still the Duke the reigning member
is moving looking for some food it
doesn't look extremely full very
opportunistic he knows he's got to move
he's probably been waiting all day as he
goes around the corner there just had
some tracks of him this morning scent
marking not far from where we found
wasana and so that he would have done as
soon as the rain had fallen so as to
basically eliminate any competition of a
rival male moving in because if a rival
male moves in and doesn't smell the
fresh scent mark well he'll think this
area is available and up for grabs
nights in Ghana doesn't want that you'd
rather allow the individual to walk into
a wall of fresh leopard scent to
obviously weed are to the weak from the
strong
quite commonplace with most territorial
animals that use scent-marking
here he is walking beautifully in front
of us Merson aam he is a very big boy he
is a beautiful boy now we're going to
stop for one second he's going to rub
his face in this bush they do quite like
the Guara bushes he's going to rub his
face and he's gonna do characteristic
backward urine spray but still no
calling cuz I suppose while he's on this
territorial prowl
he might attempt catch himself some
dinner while he's at it
so him rubbing his face is giving his
the gland on the face a wipe on the
plant as well as the urine and to us we
could maybe smell and with smell the
sweetness of the leopard scent but we
wouldn't be able to tell exactly what's
going on but to lipids they know
everything smell it now pick up on on
the six on the size and the maturity on
all of those all of those attributes
that we can only we can't even fathom
well it seems like david has positioned
himself in a beautiful spot to watch the
sunset let's go over to him for a quiet
moment well done Steve of all forgetting
Hosanna the Duke of that area what a
beautiful plant
he used especially with his big julep
and we are having a great sunset here
look at that beauty of the Mara very
good job Archie see how Archie does his
magic on the camera work showing us the
Ola roller as compliment in the
background there but he'll you see there
all that his government you see there
he's good Oh lalala I'm sure you can be
able to see all along this Cup meant the
Savannah the open you know grassland and
the Lions together excellent very good
job and you're back to a coalition of
the triangle boys and the one on the
right is the short tail you
ShoreTel did you hear me tell up again
if you want to
joy I like the way your first senior
question because it's true
that's hotel I would say is kind of a
disadvantage for him to keep the flies
out he's just like having an elephant
with some short trunk you need the whole
length and the whole how the body works
you know how the brain works to relate
to the Flies and to communicate after
the very end of the tip of the tail as
it moves it and joy or degree with you I
mean that is the downside for it to keep
higher the Flies if he was a tooth out
say it could even be more of a
disadvantage because cheetahs really
used they tell sometimes as a rod
but luckily lions do not do that but I
agree with you joy totally that does a
bigger disadvantage for you know she for
the short tail to use his teeth to flick
away the Flies look at the amount of
flies joy he got on his body
my guess is if I was a short tail is
just to roll over and maybe crush or
kill has been as you can see what he is
doing joy you see that and I'm not sure
that she's of much help but being a leaf
flex feeling that that's what it's meant
to do well the flies go or not
he just keep flicking the tail I'm not
sure in my next life I'd want to be a
lion and just stay there and enjoy life
not wondering what could happen to me
Wow down short tell what you want to do
now turn around or just tus oh yeah I
feel sorry for short sell because of
that I don't know how much flies he gets
out of his body by doing that and funny
enough the one on the left the fun
Archie does it have as many flies I
don't know how I'd be able to explain
this yeah joy if you look you know the
other nice viewers if you look on these
two up the vents of these two boys here
one the short tail has more flies than
the fun lion he got a few a few scars as
you can see there but not as many flies
I don't know how I would be able to
explain that let's go back to that one
there
you see more invasion of the Flies and
the fun is it edge do they got something
or are they getting something they're
not getting on the other you know all
the fun called a certain definitely a
feeling about something there and I'll
be trying to investigate this and find
out and I spotted cut weed Tristen well
we are still with Hasani
but he is going to go unfortunately
where a vehicle can't go if he carries
on in his course now he's he's mobile
kind of in a northwesterly direction now
into the drainage line of English alley
which is normally if can kind of pass
through in places but where he's gone is
I'm afraid impenetrable it really is
going to be impossible to follow him
from yeah the only way to do it would be
to maybe try get around the other side
onto English alley and wait for him
there but I don't know which direction
he's going he seems like he spotted
something so I don't think we're gonna
be able to keep up with him at all I'm
afraid which is a bit of a pity let's
try and see I seems like they might be a
little gap there I don't know if we're
gonna be able to I've tried this once
before and I remember I didn't get very
far and I'm not sure if I'm going to be
stupid or brave trying to do this again
because I'm pretty sure I know what the
outcome of this is going to be is that
I'm not going to be able to get to him
do you see you on the top there though
if you come out a bit urgh there's a big
Marilla that's bet the back in the
background so you see it now that's
where English Leroy drun so it's not too
far so I think that's rather goes that
way then trying to crash through yeah I
don't think we're gonna get this right
all right
like I say I remember that this will
just be stupidity rather than bravery to
do this because we're just not gonna get
anywhere all right while we do that so
that send you across to Stevie's with
Dingaan and I'm actually quite
interested to know where Tenggara is
given that husana is Mobile Northwest
yes he's gone a lot more West than he
was initially going tryst
we're now on Rebecca's road after
getting through that very interesting
drainage he's now I'm over moving sort
of west towards Zoe's I think anyway
yeah from my recollection of the road
we've just popped out in it but I think
we're coming up towards the sort of
Rebecca's and Zuri's Junction but he's
walking in the road now thankfully we've
had to do some interesting sideways well
not sideways but interesting up and down
messaging messaging is that even a word
but now he's walking beautifully in the
red he still hasn't called but he's been
sent marking deliberately as he goes yes
so exactly where I thought we were
exactly where I thought to where there's
a big Junction here with mrs. Rebecca's
and there's Zoe's road and that road
over there goes all the way to the West
an area where that uncle boomers in
Paula's just over there okay while they
are in parlor just ahead of us here
through the thickets on the right and on
the left grace you want to know if a
signer will be will take over from ting
garner you know it's not normally what
happens grace what normally happens is a
male leopard gets pushed away from his
natal area and he moves off to go and
get stronger and eventually breed far
away from his sort of genetic line okay
well he spotted those Impala this could
be very exciting it's quite a nice area
with regards to to being able to keep up
with him it might be worth inviting a
few more viewers makes there's two small
herds of Impala one on the right and one
on the left and he's going very low he's
not being very stealthy at the moment
but cats like to use the roads to mask
their scent with regards the footfalls
but he doesn't seem to be too bothered
let's give it a moment and see if
there's in parlor spot him here we go
that's what he likes to do as soon as he
gets spotted he calls oh well I've been
spotted I might as well let everybody
know where I am and that's what he just
did
he's not very interested in food right
now he's on a territorial mission yeah
sorry makes I I thought he might be
interested in the Impala there but he's
more interested in demarcating a
territory here I'll just move over here
maybe get a bit of a two-shot with the
Impala and the leopard look at how
defiantly close the Impala actually come
this is awesome stuff they're not too
worried about a cat that they can see
very high-pitched nasal alarm call not
to be confused with the rottens a whole
lot of animals shouting at the same time
and look how he defiantly just walks he
doesn't care this is his spot we just
talked on the radio
Bester prett got justin is dealing with
that someone was looking for us and this
leopard Tristan has managed to talk to
him before we have so that's great I'll
give another a little update as soon as
we see where he turns at the corner they
you live another day in parlors and live
another day they quite happy that they
spotted him
I'll even follow him until they can't
see him anymore I'll keep moving and
keep moving which way you're going to go
my boy
I think he's gonna turn right there yes
he is Zephir that's exactly it's the
confidence that he exudes is incredible
he's still showing it he's given up the
limp that he had
okay we're gonna keep pulling it around
the corner here
lovely hearing those Impala shouting
[Music]
it's gonna change out of range one
second he walks so let me just give an
update no specialist in Ghana is now
mobile directly along Zoe's road towards
quarantine area once there shall unlock
okay
there he goes he's basically walking an
entire route he's gonna walk an entire
route he's obviously he's done it many
times before very good chance is gonna
walk straight past Gallagher sort of
area and up into the north again because
he's going to demarcate everything that
is his so a lot of the viewers love the
sawing sound is one of the nicest sounds
in the African wilderness to hear a
sawing I love hearing it when I wake up
in the morning or hearing it when I just
art any time in the day we'd hang on a
second Zhaan's oh is now mobile north
towards quarantine area Matt call again
not sure but it's mainly the demarcation
of the territory through the urine
that's important that is sort of a one
week to two weeks sort of maintenance
until this some more rain that is the
calling there is an immediate response
so basically by calling he's indicating
to all of the other leopards around that
he is here right now there we go we just
watch him continue walking down the road
this beautiful big mare lipid let's go
back to David who's still with the big
male lion
well Kangana you have a computer here
look at the size of this huge male here
and he is so big
sorry about that and this is the short
tale he decided to wake up repositioned
himself and look at the short tail there
and fun is Fredd behind him and if you
look at both of them you can see a huge
difference on their main short tail got
a bigger man and much darker in color
compared Fung
I want you've used to tell me between
the two the faces if you don't put into
account from the main which one looks
also begun which one looks ferocious or
which one looks friendly
I don't know what you think of that look
on that face Shambo Fung are you doing
kimly two huge metal ions great comment
there and it could be better and this is
one of the beauties of maybe coming to
Africa on a safari
we are Lea showed you females we have
been showing you leopards all over and
now we got two male lions Kimberly and
it could be better than this so one of
them still enjoying the nap the other
than just licking its paw
doing a bit of know the fun on the left
there but of grooming himself
ShoreTel what are you thinking and I
might have mentioned earlier the females
or the pride of the marsh pride is not
very far from where we are is about two
kilometres about a mile and a half or so
from here and sometimes the male's just
hung around the females so that if you
know they go for a kill they guaranteed
of getting some food from grooming
himself much shorter main them short
tail is a scar
do you think that is a scar there
Holly I will tell you for a fact I have
no idea what might have happened to its
tail because since it came to the Mara I
found it you know that way and there
could be all the theories you know it
could been bitten by another male it
could have been born like that but Holly
forgive me because I do not have a good
answer for you I might find out maybe
ask for my senior guides James Henry or
maybe Brent who may know for a fact what
might have happened to tell will only
guess you know as I'm saying give some
theories if you go back to that tale
born like that could have been a defect
could have been sickness could have been
bitten by another male you know males
they fight you know over territories
when they are taking over for example
the coalition's when they overthrowing
another coalition so triangle boys as I
said earlier they have been doing very
well
so Holly I will not know for a fact what
might have happened to it is tell not
very many Lions have seen this we have
another female around here of a
different set of pride that is called as
Sasha pride where one of the femurs has
like a kinky tail so all these things we
have always seen out here in the bush
and Steve will be telling us something
in South Africa yes well we have
switched over to the infrared spectrum
and infrared light and here is the Duke
he's just done some scent marking and
maybe he needed a little bit more of
maybe number two at the same time he
managed to get around him and he should
come wandering down the road towards us
hang on one second he is still on the
road just on mobile north okay that's
just another landowner come it to join
us should have another vehicle in the
sighting shortly I don't hear it yet
though they're beautiful big neck of his
it's not as pretty as his son has been
in a few more battles
it's got enormous feet though there's
big feet
here he is what a beautiful gentleman
okay ride past us
he is a very relaxed male we do get to
spend quite a bit of time with him which
is magical sorry about the back of a
vehicle there Craig doing his swivel
let's just turn around
he's going to you can tell by the way
that the cat is moving Catherine he is
looking really really good that limp
that he had is completely gone
completely gone
which is nice okay so we have a vehicle
joining us in a moment as ting Ghana
continues on his patrol you can tell by
the fact that is used in the road and
scent-marking as he goes that he indeed
is using it to cover more distance it's
much quicker just like us driving on the
road I'm just going to let this vehicle
know that he's coming up yeah we're
about 80 meters from you if you just
want to pull over on the side of the
road there and he should walk past you
in a few moments we don't want to block
him obviously
pull off off the road so that the
leopard can walk past they want to block
his route Lindsey I don't know if it's
more concentrated I know that certain
animals have the ability to sort of
increase the concentration confrontation
okay so Lindsey I think with the Gods
two cats they got the same amount of
confrontation all the time and really
just is it's a constant thing a
territory is defended all the time it's
not stopped till that normal dies or
they they pass it on or they lose it to
the next individual so the
confrontations with regards to cats are
happening all the time but that's the
reason why they mark territory the
marking of territory actually limits the
confrontation potential if there didn't
have a territory marking then every time
they saw a leopard they would just fight
there'd be no indicator to say occupancy
it would just be a constant battle all
the time so but using the energy to
demarcate you indicating to others that
you're there you're strong you're
willing to fight so there's the other
vehicle we're gonna see if we can catch
up with him
was very exciting landowners bring their
families here in the parks they just on
the South Road like we did in a big male
leopard walking right past you
it's really there's nothing better
nothing better
okay he's inviting me to go first
good evening
okay I'm going to park on the side of
the red it says to do a bit of a leap
frogging floyd very easy you can see how
easy our drive in the road it's very
comfortable to drive the road here have
you ever taken I don't know a float if
you drive but maybe don't do it but
think about it if you took your car and
you drove on a tarmac Road quite
something fast it's quite comfortable
isn't it
take your same kind drive it through the
grass or through the vegetation it's not
as comfortable yeah you lots of
obstacles lots of things in the way you
can't move as quickly have to go very
slowly holds all sorts of things that
can obscure you and the also you'll make
a lot more noise so leopards will do it
they can cover a much greater distance
by walking in the road there quiet
there's no obstacles you can just walk
and focus on his territory focus on
moving not focus on having to navigate
around branches and trees and stuff and
the road for example is basically just
an adaptation of what game paths would
be and lipids Lions runners elephant all
these animals were used game pause
neutral game paths to navigate and it's
just become the part and parcel of how
these animals demarcated territories by
using roads which they just see is a big
game path a big hippo path and luck well
this will suit me so why don't I I'll
just wave these guys past just a big
game path and to walk on Adi market so
that's exactly what they want to do okay
well we are going to go back over to
Tristan we're going to fish to stay with
this obviously this lovely gentleman
let's go to Tristan and see what his
plans are for the last moments of drive
well good luck enjoy staying with him
Steve I'm sure Steve is very happy that
he found himself the leopard this
afternoon he was going to spend time
with the Duke as long as we have all
that we arts and about so unfortunate we
didn't find for Sanne again and part of
me didn't really want to find him I know
that's gonna sound very odd but we spent
the entire afternoon with him it's now
time that he's hunting and crashing
through that area there is just going to
ruin his off evening hunt and it's going
to make it very difficult for him so I
would rather he has his own time to do
what he needs to do and I would rather
he has his own kind of hunting time that
we don't disturb him he gives us so much
that it's better that he gets a little
bit of alone time too and he's going to
go to the damn kami way so you guys will
get to see him a little bit later I'm
pretty sure about it unless he kills
between here and there Monique are there
any fences up between sabi sand and
Kruger no is the answer to that fences
were dropped in 1993 I'm not mistaken 93
or 94 and then you found that animals
and are transient through so there's no
fence between the two of them it allows
a nice movement of animals up and down
and all around and that's why we
fortunate to be in this area because you
just never know what's gonna happen you
never know what's coming your way we get
elephants from all over the place we get
new male lion blood we get new male
lipids that cook amory that came out of
the Kruger and then so it's really
important that we have an open system
the bigger the system the more the
animals have to roam the more natural
the ecosystem becomes and the less
interference man has to have in there a
small system man's got to control
populations because otherwise you end up
with over grazing or too many predators
that kill too much so you need to have
that balance and it's important that
that fence is done right I'm going to
carry on I'm hitting my way home now
towards quarantine while I do that
though I'm going to send you back up to
David for his last mention of the day I
believe he is still sitting with his big
furry cats
well the marsh pride continued to give
us lots of joy and look at a mother and
a youngster they're just earthling and
having some good fun
think is one mother and two cubs and you
can tell now we are in infrared it's
getting dark and we'll always do the
best we can not to interfere with the
natural living style and not shining
lights Oh spotlights on their faces and
look at how beautiful that is and the
magic of infrared that's the mother bear
you were raised up hello there good Lily
you only got two cups
shrim I would say we are one hour ahead
of Jummah in South Africa and I'm
looking at my watch and it's saying is
about three minutes to seven and in June
when Kruger National Park in South
Africa it should be three minutes to six
of course noise two minutes in some 55
seconds so we have one hour difference
between us here in Kenya and in South
Africa thank you for your question and
the mama has decided to go on tummy
mount and I'm sure the Cubs would slowly
and surely follow her hello there voice
you have a brother sister who rose up
and may be going to join the other
previous so earlier rosalie depending on
the age of the lion is anything three to
four feet depending on the age of
clients on average a length over lion
tail of course it's a small little guy
here could be about foot and something
but the big one still fully grown could
be three going up to four feet
you know max with a fully grown ones
just walking the grass there and it's
exactly what I was saying earlier as it
cools off they cast tend to be more
active and more so lions hello there are
you wanna play old you just want to keep
mom busy are you looking for anything
you can feed on in the grass not sure
you can hear that but this one look old
mmm-hmm from the background there and
I'm trying to imagine maybe this one
lioness he's trying to touch base with
the fried with so before
hello there what are you looking at were
you thinking he's trying to sniff the
big engine and getting all the diesel
fumes scratching the ground their
abilities to see I just walk in the
middle of the grass and most likely they
might regroup with the rest of them
that's a good jump good play and any day
I see lions is always a great day and
today I would say it has been a day full
of cuts going to South Africa ting Ghana
you know Hosanna and the marsh pride
here the triangle boys fantastic what a
joy and on behalf all teams in South
Africa and you can you thank you very
much and we'll see you tomorrow goodbye
for now